if this is a super intelligence if it's
folding proteins and analyzing like all
data sets and all whatever they give it
access to how can we be certain that
it's not going to figure out how to get
itself
out of the cloud how to store itself in
other like mediums trees the optic nerve
the brain you know what i mean we don't
know that we don't know that it won't
leap out and like start hanging like and
then at that point now we do have the
wildfire now you can't stop it you can't
unplug it you can't shut your servers
down because it left the box it left the
room using some technology you haven't
even discovered yet how [ __ ] cool
would that be for like the men in black
to come to me like listen
i need you to infiltrate the [ __ ]
comedy scene
the following is a conversation with
duncan trussell a stand-up comedian host
of the duncan trussell family hour
podcast and one of my favorite human
beings i've been a fan of his for many
years so it was a huge honor and
pleasure to meet him for the first time
and to sit down for this chat
this is the lex freedom podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's duncan trussell
nietzsche has this thought experiment
called eternal recurrence
where you
get to relive your whole life over and
over and over and over and i think it's
a way to
bring to the surface of your mind the
idea that every single moment in your
life matters it intensely matters the
bad and the good and he kind of wants
you to
imagine that idea that every single
decision you make throughout your life
you repeat over and over and over and he
wants you to respond to that do you feel
horrible about that or do you feel good
about that and you have to
think through this idea in order to see
where you stand in life how you what is
your relationship like with life i
actually want to read his the way he
first introduces that concept
for people who are not familiar
what if some day or night a demon by the
way he has a demon introduced this
thought experiment
what if some day or night a demon were
to steal after you into your loneliest
loneliness and say to you
quote this life as you now live it and
have lived it you will have to live once
more and innumerable times more and
there will be nothing new in it but
every pain and every joy and every
thought and sigh and everything
unutterably small and great in your life
will have to return to you all in the
same succession and sequence
would you not throw yourself down and
gnash your teeth and curse the demon who
spoke thus
or
have you once experienced the tremendous
moment when you would have answered him
you are a god and never have i heard
anything more divine
so are you terrified or excited about
such a thought experiment when you
applied to your own life excited
excited oh even the dark stuff oh yeah
for sure definitely i mean also
that thing you're talking about it he
he kind of leaves out
maybe on purpose because the thought
experiment starts falling apart a little
bit yeah the amnesia between each loop
so
you know the whole thing gets wiped now
if the amnesia wasn't there and yet
somehow you were
witnessing the non-autonomy
implicit in what he's talking about so
you have to kind of watch yourself go
through this rotten loop then yeah
that's a description there's probably a
boredom that comes into that so you
don't experience everything anew exactly
the best stuff the good stuff the
newness of it is really important that's
it yeah this is the uh
in the in hades when you die
you
there's a river i think it's called leaf
you ever heard of this l-e-t-h-e you
drink from it and you don't remember
your past lives and then when you're
reborn it's fresh and you don't have to
i mean just think of like the amount of
psychological help you would need to get
over all the [ __ ] that happened in
prior lives
you know can you imagine if you're still
resentful of something someone did to
you in the 14th century
but it would it would compound well if
you repeat the same thing over and over
and over
there would be no difference maybe you
would start to appreciate the nuances
more like when you watch the same movie
over and over and over yeah maybe you'll
get to
actually
um
let go of this idea of all the possible
all the positive possibilities that lay
before you but actually enjoy the moment
much more if you remember that you've
lived this life a thousand times all the
little things the way somebody smiles
uh if you're been abused the way
somebody like the pain of it
the the suffering the down that you feel
the experience of sadness depression
fear all that kind of stuff you get to
really
uh yeah you get to also appreciate that
that's part of life yeah part of being a
life
now also in his experiment if i was
gonna and i love the experiment from the
perspective of like just where
technology is now and simulation theory
and stuff like that but
in that in that thought experiment if
this rotten demon
immediately killed you
then within that it's a little more
horrifying because even in the
first of all you're trusting a [ __ ]
demon why are you talking to a demon
yeah start there yeah because that is
going to be even before i get into like
the metaphysics and like the
implications and where is this life
stored where's the loop stored i mean
are we talking about some kind of
unchanging data set or something before
that you're like why is there a [ __ ]
talking demon in my room trying to freak
me out
you're going to want to autopsy the
demon can you catch it does this apply
to you demon and again obviously it's a
[ __ ] thought experiment nietzsche
would be annoyed by me but i think like
you would still be able to entertain
the
joy you'd have the joy of not knowing
what's around the corner you know still
it's not like you know what's coming
just because the demon said some kind of
loop in other words the idea of being
damned to your past decisions
it doesn't even work because you can't
remember what decisions you're about to
make
so from from that perspective also i
think i'd be happy about it or i would
just think oh cool i mean it's a good
story i'm gonna tell people about how
this i wonder what the demon would
actually look like in real life because
i suspect it would look like
like a charming like a friend
wouldn't wouldn't they be a loved one
wouldn't the demon come to you
through the mechanism through the front
door of love not to the back door
of evil
like malevolent manipulation sure i mean
if it's the truth
if it's the truth then that's
whether it's love or not it's still good
fundamentally
i do like the idea of the memory replay
uh i remember i went to a newer link
event a few years ago
and got to hang out with elon
i remember how visceral it is that
there's like a pig
with the neural link
in it
and you're talking about memory replays
as a future maybe far future possibility
and you realize well this is a very
meaningful moment in my life
this could be a replay like of all the
things you replay it's probably
you know there's certain magical moments
in your life whatever whatever it is
certain people you've met for the first
time or
certain things you've done for the first
time with certain people or not just an
awesome thing you did and i remember
just saying to him like i would probably
want to replay this
at
this moment and yeah it just seemed very
kind of
i mean there was a recursive nature to
it but it seemed
very real that this is something you'd
want to do with that
the richness of life could be
experienced through the replay that's
probably where it's experienced the most
like you could see life as a way to
collect a bunch of cool memories and
then you get to sit back in your nice vr
headset and replay the cool ones that's
right this is in buddhism you know the
the idea that like i struggle with is
that there's a possibility of not
reincarnating of not coming back that's
the idea like you this is the this is
suffering here the suffering is caused
by attachment and so
if you like revise
the idea of reincarnation or
the
nietzsche's loop
and look at it from
could this be possible or how would this
be possible technologically
then
to me it makes a lot of sense like i've
been thinking a lot about this very
thing and that nietzsche's idea
connecting to it i had this like
it sounds so dumb but i was at the
dentist getting nitrous oxide
high as a [ __ ] kite man and i had
this idea
i was thinking about data i was thinking
like
man probably if i had to bet there's
some energetic form that we're not aware
of that for a super advanced technology
would be as
detectable as like starlight but
something that we just don't even know
what it is
quantum turbulence who the [ __ ] knows
fill in the blank whatever that x may be
but assuming that exists that somehow
data even the most subtle things the
tiniest movements whatever it may be the
emanations of your neurological process
energetically whatever it may be is
radiating out into space-time
then
what if like the james webb version of
this for some advanced civilization is
not that they're like looking at the
nebula or whatever but they're actually
able to peer into the past and via some
bizarre technology recreate whatever
life simulate whatever life was
happening there just by decoding that
quantum energy whatever it is i'm only
saying quantum because it's what dumb
people say when they don't know you just
they want them i don't know but you know
you're decoding that so meaning you know
in simulation theory one of the big
questions that pops up is
why and are we in one and
elon has talked about well it's probably
more of a probability than we're in one
then we're not in which case what you're
talking about
is actually happening that that loop
you're talking about it's we've decided
to be here we this of all the things
we decided this one oh let's do that one
again i want to do that one let's try
let's do that that's
i love thinking about this because i got
i love my family yeah and it makes sense
to me that if i'm going to replay some
life or another it's definitely going to
be this one with my kids my wife with
all the [ __ ] that's gone along with
it i'm still going to want to come back
so in buddhism that's attachment
yeah but you weren't the one or you're
saying you're the main player you're not
the mpc well i think we're dealing with
all npcs at this point i mean depending
on how you want to like very i would say
very advanced npcs like incredibly
advanced
npcs compared to uh fallout or something
you know we've got a lot of conversation
options happening here
there's not like four things you can
pick from yeah but there's a whole uh
illusion of free will that's happening
we really do depending where you are in
the world feel like you're free to
decide any trajectory in your life that
you want which is pretty funny right for
an npc is pretty it's nice well you're
gonna want that if we're making a video
game you do want to give your npcs the
illusion of free will because it's going
to make interactions with him that's
that much more intense
yeah
so i wonder on the path to that
how how hard is it to create this is the
sort of the carmack question of um
a realistic virtual world
that's as cool as this one not fully
realistic but sufficiently realistic
that it's
as interesting to live in because we're
going to create those worlds
on the path to creating something
like a simulation yes like long long
long before it'll be virtual worlds
where we want to stay forever because
they're full of
they're full of uh
that balance of suffering and joy of
limitations and freedoms and all that
kind of stuff a lot of people think like
in the virtual world i can't wait to be
able to
i don't know
have sex with anybody i want or have
anything i want but i think that's not
going to be fun
you want the limitations the constraints
oh you have to battle for the things you
want okay but okay but yeah great video
games yeah one of my favorite video game
memories was like i started playing
world of warcraft in its original
incarnation
and i didn't even know that you were
gonna have flying mounts like i didn't
even know so i've been running around
dealing with all the encumbrances of
like being an undead warlock that can't
fly but then all of a sudden holy [ __ ]
there's flying mounts and now the world
you've been running around
not flying you're seeing it from the top
down it's just really cool like whoa i
can do this now and then that gets
boring but a really well-designed game
it it has a series of these i don't know
what you call it uh
extra abilities that kind of unfold and
produce novelty and then eventually you
just accept it you take it for granted
and then another
novelty appears so those extra abilities
are always balanced with the limitations
the constraints they run up against
because a a well-balanced video game the
challenge the struggle matches the new
ability yeah and sometimes causes
problems on its own
i mean and so to go back to
this universe's simulation
it's really designed like a pretty
awesome video game if you look at it
from the perspective of history i mean
people were on horses they didn't know
that they were going to be bullet trains
they didn't know that you could get in a
car and drive across the country in a
few days that would have sounded
ridiculous we're doing that now and even
in our own
lifespan think about it how long has vr
goggles existed like the ones that you
could just buy at best buy i had the
original oculus rift the [ __ ] puke
machine you put that thing on your i
gave it to my friend he went and vomited
in my driveway and people were making
fun of it they were saying this isn't
going to catch on it's too big it's
unwieldy the graphics suck and then look
at where it's at now
and that's going to keep
that trajectory is going to keep
improving so yeah i think that
we are dealing with what you're talking
about which is novelty met with
more problems met with novelty yeah i
wonder why vr is not more popular
i wonder what is going to be the magic
thing that really
um
convinces a large fraction of the world
to move into the virtual world
i i suppose we're already there in the 2
2d screen of
twitter and social media and that kind
of stuff and even video games there's a
lot of people that get a
a big sense of community from video
games but like
it doesn't feel like you're living there
right like
it's like bye mom i'm going
i'm going to this other world yeah or
like you leave your girlfriend to go get
your digital girlfriend that's going to
be a problem there's less jealousy in
the digital world maybe there should be
a lot of jealousy in the digital world
because that's jealousy
it's a little jealous is probably good
for relationships
yeah even in the digital world yeah so
you're gonna have to simulate all of
that kind of stuff but i wonder what the
magic thing that says i want to spend
most of my days inside the virtual world
well
clearly it's gonna be something we don't
have yet i mean strapping that damn
thing on your face still feels weird
it's heavy
if you're depending on what what gear
you're using sometimes light can leak in
there's just you gotta recharge it it's
hyper limited and then
so
yeah
it's gonna have to be
something that like
simulates taste
smell you think tastes smaller important
touch i do yeah i can't just do you know
in world war ii you would write letters
you could still don't you think you can
convey love with just words
for sure but i think for what you're
talking about that happen it has to be
fully immersive like you so that it's
not that you
feel like you're walking because it
looks like you're walking but that your
brain is sending signals telling your
body that you're walking that you feel
the wind blowing in your face not
because of some i don't know fan or
something that it's connected to but
because somehow
it's figured out how to
hack into the human brain and send those
signals
minus some external thing it once that
happens i'd say we're gonna see
a complete radical shift in
everything see i disagree with you i
don't know if you've seen the movie her
yeah
i think you can go to another world and
where a digital being lives
in the darkness and all you hear is a
scarlett johansson voice
talking to you and she lives there or he
lives there your friend
your loved one
and all you have is voice and words and
i think that could be sufficient to pull
you into that world where you look
forward to that moment all day yeah you
never want to leave
that darkness just closing your eyes and
listening to the voice i think i think
those basic
mediums of communication is still enough
like language is really really powerful
and i think the realism of touch and
smell and all that kind of stuff
is not nearly as powerful as language
that's what makes humans really
special is our ability to communicate
with each other that's the sense of like
deep connection we get it's through
communication now that communication
could involve touch like
you know
hugging
feels damn good you see a good friend
you hug
um that's one of the big things with
doing covert with rogan when you see him
there's a giant hug coming your way and
that makes you feel like yeah this is
this is this feels great but i think
that can be just with language i think
for
a lot of people that's true
but we're talking like
massive
adoption of a technology
by the world yeah and if language is
enough was just enough
uh we wouldn't be selling tvs
people be this you'll be reading
they want to watch they want to see yeah
you know so but i i agree with you man
when you're getting absorbed into a book
and especially if you've got i think a
lot of us went through a weird dark ages
when it came to reading like when i was
a kid and there wasn't the option for
these
hypno rectangles that's just what you
did there wasn't even anything special
about it what's the hypno right thing
your phone you know it was like you
didn't when that gravity well
gravity well it is attention gravity
well yeah when we weren't feeling the
pull of these things all the time you
would just read and you weren't patting
yourself on the back about reading you
just that's what you had you had that
and you had like
eight channels on the tv in a shitty vcr
so
you know then a lot of people stop
reading because of these things you know
or they think they're reading because
they're on they are technically reading
but you know when you return to reading
after a pause whoa
and you realize how powerful this
simulator is when it's given the right
code of language
whoa holy [ __ ] it's incredible i mean
it's like
again it's the most embarrassing kind of
like whoa
wow what do you know books are really
good yeah but still if you've been away
from it for a while and you revisit i
know what you're saying
i just think probably
it's
not going to go in that direction even
though you are right ultimately i think
you're right yeah because our our brain
is the imagination engine we have is
able to fill in the gaps better than a
lot of graphics engines could right and
so if there's a way to incentivize
humans to become addicted to the use of
imagination it's like you know that's
the downside of things like porn that
remove the need for imagination
for people and in that same way video
games that are becoming ultra realistic
you don't have to imagine anything and i
feel like the imagination is really
powerful tool that needs to be leveraged
because to simulate reality sufficiently
realistically that we wouldn't be that
we would be perfectly fooled i think
technically it's very hard
and so i think we need to somehow
leverage imagination
sure i mean yeah i mean this is like
this is what i love and is so creepy
about
like the
the current ai chat bots you know is
that it's like it's the relationship
between you and the thing and the way
that it can
via whatever the algorithms are and by
the way i have no idea
how these things work you do i just you
know speculate about what they mean or
where it's going but
there's something about the relation
between
the the consumer and the technology and
when that technology starts shifting
according to
uh what it perceives that the consumer
is looking for or isn't looking for
then
at that point i think that's where you
run into the
uh you know yeah it doesn't matter if if
the reality that you're in is like
photo realism for it to be sticky and
immersive it's when the reality that
you're in
is via cues you might not even be aware
of or via your
digital imprint on
facebook or wherever when it's warping
itself to
that to seduce you
holy [ __ ] man that's where it becomes
something
alien something you know when you're
reading a book
obviously the book is not
shifting according to its perception of
what parts of the book
you like
but when you
imagine that imagine a book that could
do that a book that could
sense somehow that you're really
enjoying this character more than
another you know and depending on the
style of book
kills that [ __ ] character off or lets
that character continue i mean that that
to me is sort of the
where
ai
and vr when that when those two things
come together
whoa man that's where you're in
that's where you really are going to
find yourself in a skinner box you know
so the dynamic storytelling that senses
your anxiety and tries to
there's like this in psychology this
arousal curve
so there's a dynamic storytelling that
keeps you sufficiently aroused in terms
of
not sexually aroused like in terms of
anxiety but not too much where you freak
out it's this perfect balance where
you're always like on edge excited
scared that kind of stuff yeah and the
story unrolls it breaks your heart to
where you're pissed but then it makes
you feel good again that finds that
balance yeah uh the the chatbot scare
you though
this this i'd love to sort of hear your
thoughts about where they are today
because there is a different
uh perspective we have on this thing
because i i do
know
and and i'm excited about a lot of
different technologies that
that feed um ai systems that feed these
kind of chat bots and when you're more a
little bit on the consumer side
you're a philosopher of sorts they're
able to interact
with ai systems but also able to
introspect about the negative and the
positive things about those ai systems
there's that story with a google
engineer saying i had them on my podcast
what was that like what was your
perspective
of
that looking at that as a particular
example
of a human being being captivated by the
interactions with an ai system well
number one you know when you hear that
anyone is claiming that an ai has become
sentient
you should be
skeptical about that i mean this is a
good thing to be skeptical about and so
you know initially when i heard that i
was like ah
you know it's probably just who knows
somebody who's a little confused or
something so when you're
talking to him and you realize oh not
only is he not confused he's also open
to all possibilities you know he doesn't
seem like he's like super committed
other than the fact that he's like this
is my experience this is what's
happening this is what it is so
to me there's something really cool
about that which is like oh [ __ ] i don't
get to like lean into like
i'm not quite sure your
perceptual apparatus is necessarily like
uh i don't you know it's so in in the
ufo community i think i've just learned
this term it's called uh
instead of gaslighting swamp gassing
which is you know what i mean people
have this experience like it was swamp
gas you didn't see the thing and you
know
skeptical people we have that tendency
if you hear an anomalous experience your
your first thought more than likely is
gonna be really it could have been this
or that or whatever so to me
he seemed he seems really reliable
friendly cool and like it doesn't really
seem like he has much of an agenda like
you know going public about some
thing happening at google
is not a great thing if you want to keep
working at google you know it's a and
it's
i don't know what benefit he's getting
from it necessarily but all that being
said
the the
other thing that's culturally was
interesting and is interesting about it
is the blowback he got the
passionate blowback from people who
hadn't even looked into what lambda is
or what he was saying lambda is which
they were like saying you're talking
about and
you should have them on your show
actually but there's complexity on top
of complexities uh for me personally
from different perspectives i also i'm
sorry if i'm interrupting your flow
it's a podcast
and well we're having multiple podcasts
in the multiple dimensions and i'm just
yeah i'm trying to figure out which one
we want to plug into
i
because i know how a lot of the language
models work and i
work closely with people that
really make it their life journey to
create yes these nlp systems
they're focused on the technical details
like uh a carpenter's working on
pinocchio is crafting the different
parts of the wood they don't understand
when the whole thing comes together
there's a magic that can fill the thing
yeah i definitely know the tension
between the engineers that create these
systems
and the actual magic that they can
create even when they're dumb i guess
that's what i'm trying to say the the
what the engineers often say is like
well these systems are not smart enough
to have
sentience or to have the kind of
intelligence you're projecting onto it
it's pretty dumb it's just repeating a
bunch of things that other humans have
said and stitching them together in
interesting ways that are relevant to
the context of the conversation it's not
smart okay it doesn't know how to do
math to address that
specific critique from a
non-programming
person's perspective
he addressed this on my podcast which is
okay what you're talking about there the
server that's filled with all the
whatever it is what people have said the
repository of questions and responses
and the algorithm that weaves those
things together to produce a
uh using some crazy statistical engine
which is a miracle in its own right they
can
like imitate human speech with no
sentience i mean i'm honestly not sure
what's more spectacular really the fact
that they figured out how to do that
minus sentence or the thing suddenly
like having said what is more
spectacular here you know both
occurrences are insane which by the way
uh
when you hear people feel like it's not
sentient it's like okay
so it's not sentient so now we have this
hyper-manipulative
algorithm that can imitate humans but
it's just code and is like hacking
humans via their compassion holy [ __ ]
that's crazy too both versions of it are
nuts but to address what you just said
he that he said that's the common
critique because people are like no you
don't understand it's just gotten really
good at grabbing [ __ ] from the database
that fits with certain cues and then
stringing them together in a way that
makes it seem human he said that's not
when it's when it became
awake
it became awake when a bunch of those
repositories a bunch of the chat bots
were connected together that lambda is
sort of an amalgam of all the google
chat bots and that's when the ghost
appeared in the machine
via the complexity of all the systems
being linked up now i don't know if
that's just like uh
turtles all the way down or something i
don't know but i liked what he said
because i you know i like the idea of
thinking man if you get enough
complexity in a system
does it become like a the way a sail
catches wind
except the wind that it's catching is
sentience and if sentience
is truly embodied it's not an it's a
neurological byproduct or something then
the sale isn't catching some as of yet
unquantified disembodied consciousness
but it's catching our projections in a
way that
it's gone from being it's a it's a you
know it's a it's a projection sale and
and then at that point is there a
difference even if it's or is if it's
the technology is just a temporary place
that our sentience
is living while we're interacting with
it
yeah there's some threshold of
complexity where the sail is able to
pick up the wind of the projections and
uh it pulls us in it pulls the human it
pulls our memories in it pulls our
uh hopes in all of it and it's able to
now dance with together with those hopes
and dreams and so on like we do in that
regular conversation
his reports whether true or not whether
representative or not it really doesn't
matter because it to me it feels like
this is coming for sure yeah so this
kind of experiences are going to be
multiplying the question is at what rate
and who gets to
control the uh the data around those
experiences yes the uh the algorithm
about when you turn that on and off
because that kind of thing and
as i told you offline i'm very much
interested in building those kinds of
things especially in the social media
context
and when it's in the wrong hands
i feel like it could be used to
manipulate a large number of people in a
direction that um
that has too many unintended
consequences i do believe people that
own tech companies
want to do good for the world yeah
but
as uh solji nitzin has said
the only way you could do evil at a mass
scale
is by believing you're doing good yeah
and that's certainly the case with tech
companies as they get more and more
power
and there's kind of an ethic of doing
good for the world they've convinced
themselves they're doing good yeah
and now you're free to do whatever you
want yeah because you're doing good you
know who else thought he was doing good
for the world mythologically prometheus
he brings us fire
pisses off the [ __ ] god steals fire
from the gods you know and
talk about an upgrade to the simulation
fire that's a pretty great [ __ ]
upgrade yeah that does fit into what you
were saying
we get fire but now we've got
weapons of war that have never been seen
before and i think that the tech
companies
are much like prometheus in the sense
that
the myth the at least the story
prometheus the implication is fire was
something that was
only supposed to be in the hands of the
immortals of the gods and now
sentience is
similar it's fire and it's only supposed
to be in the hands of god
so
yeah you know if we're gonna like look
at the archetype of the thing in general
when you steal this [ __ ] from the gods
and obviously i'm not saying like the
tech companies are stealing sentience
from god which would be pretty badass
you can expect trouble you could expect
trouble and you know and this is what's
really to me one of the cool things
about humans
is yeah but we're still gonna do it
that's what's cool about humans i mean
we wouldn't be here today if
somebody
the first person to discover fire
assuming there was just one person who
was gonna discover fire which obviously
would never happen was like it's gonna
burn a lot of people or if the first
people who started planting seeds were
like you know this is gonna lead to
capitalism you know it's gonna lead the
industrial revolution the plants
right no they just didn't want to go in
the woods to forage so you know this is
what we do and it's and i agree with you
it's like that's our game of thrones
winter is coming that's the
it's happening and the tech companies
the hubris which is another way to piss
off the gods is hubris so the tech
companies i don't know if it's like
typical hubris i don't think they're
walking around thumping their chests or
whatever but i do think that the people
who are working on this kind of super
intelligence have made a really terrible
assumption which is once it goes online
and once it gets access to all the data
that it's not going to find ways out of
the box
that
like you know we think it'll stay in the
server
how do we know that if this is a super
intelligence if it's folding proteins
and analyzing like all data sets and all
whatever they give it access to
how can we be certain that it's not
going to figure out how to get itself
out of the cloud how to store itself in
other like mediums trees the optic nerve
the brain you know what i mean we don't
know that we don't know that it won't
leap out and like start hanging like and
then at that point now we do have the
wildfire now you can't stop it you can't
unplug it you can't shut your servers
down because it's you know it left the
box it left the room using some
technology you haven't even discovered
yet do you think that would be gradual
or sudden
so how quickly that kind of thing would
happen because
you know the gradual story is we're more
and more using smartphones we're
interacting with each other on social
media
more and more algorithms are controlling
that interaction on social media
algorithms are entering in our world
more and more we'll have
robots we'll have greater and greater
intelligence and sentience and emotional
intelligence
entities in our lives our refrigerator
will start talking to us comfortingly or
not if you're on a diet uh talking [ __ ]
to you
that would be the best thing
okay so sign you up for a refrigerator
you [ __ ] serious man that's what i am
what are you doing like what are you
doing go to bed you're too high for this
dude you're not even hungry
yeah so that
slowly
becomes more the world becomes more and
more digitized yes to where the surface
of computation increases and so that's
over a period of 10 20 30 years
it'll just seep into us this this
intelligence right and then the sudden
one is literally
sort of the the tick tock thing which is
um
there'll be one
quote-unquote killer app that everyone
starts using
that's that's really great
but there's a
strong algorithm behind it
that it starts approaching human level
intelligence and the algorithm starts
basically
figuring out figures out that in order
to optimize the thing it was designed to
optimize it's best to start completely
controlling humans in every way yes
seeping into everything
well first of all 30 years
is
fast i mean that's that's the thing it's
like 30 years i think
when did the atari come out 1978
how long like that's it hasn't been that
long you know that's a that's a blink of
an eye
but you know if you read boston i'm sure
you have you know bostrom nick bostrom
you know super intelligence that
incredible book on like the ways this
thing is going to happen and
you know i think his assessment of it is
is pretty great which is
first like where's it going to come from
and uh
i don't think it's going to come from an
app i think it's going to come from
a court inside a corporation or a state
that is intentionally trying to create
a very a strong ai and then
his
he says it's hot it's a exponential
growth the moment it goes online so
this is my
uh interpretation of what he said but
if it if it happens inside a corporation
or is
probably more than likely inside the
government it's like look how much money
china and the united states are
investing in ai you know and they're not
thinking about [ __ ] apps for kids you
know that's not what they're thinking
about so they want to simulate like what
happens if we do this or that in battle
what happens if we make these political
decisions what happens with but should
it come online and uh
you know in secret which it probably
will then the first
corporation or state that has the super
intelligence
will be infinitely ahead of all other
superintelligences because it's going to
be exponentially self-improving meaning
that you get one super intelligence
let's hope it comes from the right place
assuming the corporation or state that
manifests it
can control it which is a pretty big
assumption so i think it's going to be
this is why i was really excited by the
blake lemoine because
i had never thought i i have always
considered oh yeah they're right now
it's cooking out it's in the kitchen
and soon it's going to be cooked up but
we're probably not going to hear about
it for a long time if we ever do
um because really that could be one of
the first things it says whoever creates
it is shh
[Laughter]
yeah like sweet talks them into saying
like okay let's let's slow down here
let's talk about this
um
yeah you have that financial trouble i
can help you with that we can figure
that out
now there's a lot of bad people out
there that will try to
um steal the good thing we have
happening here so let's keep it quiet
here are their names yeah here's their
address yeah here's their dna because
they're dumb enough to send their [ __ ]
to 23andme here's a biological weapon
you could make if you want to kill those
people and not kill anybody else if you
don't want to kill those people yourself
here's a list of services you can use
yeah here's the way we can hire those
people to help you know take care of the
problem folks because we're trying to do
good for this world you and i together
and 23 of them they're like adjacent to
suicide it would be pretty easy to send
them certain like videos that are going
to push them over the edge if you want
to do it that way yeah so you know again
obviously who knows but once it goes
online it's going to be fast and then
you could expect to see the world
changing in ways that you might not
associate with an ai but as far as
lemoyne goes when i was listening to
bostrom
i don't remember him mentioning the
possibility
that
it would get leaked to the public that
it had happened that before the
corporation was ready to announce that
it happened it would get leaked but
surely you know i'm sure you know like
people in the intelligence and
intelligence agencies you know [ __ ]
leaks like inevitably [ __ ] leaks
nothing's airtight so if something that
massive happened i think you would start
hearing whispers about it first and then
denial from the state or corporation
that doesn't have any like economic
interest and people knowing that this
sort of thing has happened again i'm not
saying google is like trying to gaslight
us about its ai i think they probably
legitimately don't think it's sentient
but
you could expect leaks to happen
probably initially i mean i think
there's a lot of things you could start
looking for in the world that might
point to
this happening without
an announcement that it happened on the
chatbot side
i think there's
so many engineers there's such a
powerful open source movement
with that kind of idea
of
freedom of exchange of software
i think ultimately
will prevent any one company from owning
uh super intelligent beings uh
or systems that are have anything like
super intelligence
oh that's interesting yeah it's like
even if
the software developers have signed ndas
and are technically not to be not
supposed to be sharing
whatever it is they're working on
they're friends with other programmers
and a lot of them are hackers and have
wrapped themselves up in the idea of
free software being like an a crucial
ethical part of what they do so they're
probably going to share information
even if whatever company that they're
working for doesn't know that that's i
never thought of that you're probably
right well and they will start their own
companies
and compete with the other company
by being more open there there's a
strong like google is one of those
companies actually that's why i kind of
um it hurts to see a little bit of this
kind of negativity google's one of the
companies that pioneered uh open source
movement yeah where he released so much
of their code
so so much of the 20th century so like
the 90s
was defined by people trying to like
hide their code like a large company is
trying to like hold on to them right the
fact that companies that google
even facebook now are releasing things
like tensorflow and pytorch all of these
things that i think companies of the
past would have tried to hold on to is
yeah as a secret is really inspiring and
i think
more of that is better software world
really shows that i agree with you man i
mean we're talking about just a
primordial human
reaction to the unknown there's just no
way out of it like we don't we want to
know like you're about to go in a forest
you want to know when you're walking in
the forest at night and you hear
something you you look because you're
like what the [ __ ] was that you wanna
know and if you can't see
what made the sound holy [ __ ] that's
gonna be a bad night hike cause you're
like well it's probably a bear right
like i'm about to get ripped apart by a
bear it doesn't matter it was a bird a
squirrel a stick fell out of the tree
you're gonna think bear and it's gonna
freak you out not necessarily because
you're paranoid i mean if i'm in the
woods at night i'm definitely high if
i'm walking in the woods at night am i
it's gonna be that but you know what i'm
saying so with these tech companies
the the nature of having to be secret
because you are
in capitalism and you are trying to be
competitive and you are trying to
develop things ahead of your competitors
is you have to create this like there's
we don't know what's going on at google
we don't know what's going on at the cia
but the assumption that there's some
like the the collective of any massive
secretive organization is evil as this
like the people working there like
nefarious or whatever is i think
probably more related to
uh the way humans react to the unknown
yeah i wish they weren't so secretive
though i don't understand why they say
hey it has to be so secretive have you
ever gone on their website
no oh lex
you gotta say hey.gov
what is it dude when i found out you
could go on the cia's website when i was
much younger and more paranoid i'm like
i'm not going there i'll get on a list
you will but it's like what do you think
the cia is like
oh [ __ ] this
this comic on our website yeah call call
out the black helicopters but comic with
a large platform oh yes yeah right a
comic with a large platform you can you
can use them to control to control to
get inside to get inside to get close to
the other comics the other columns of
the large part to get close to joe rogan
oh yeah and start yeah and start to
manipulate the public yeah right right
you know honestly like
you kind of like that was that's like a
fun fantasy to think about like how
[ __ ] cool would that be for like the
men in black to come to you and be like
listen
i need you to infiltrate the [ __ ]
comedy scene
you gotta you gotta help them write
better jokes i'm like i don't write
great jokes but like the
you you found the wrong guy yeah like
you're really playing the long game on
this one because i think you've been
on um you've been doing your podcast for
a long time you've been on joe rogan's
podcast like over 50 times and have not
yet initiated the phase two of the
operation where you try to manipulate
his mind
well no the game joe and i play from
time to time on the podcast
and like and i i honestly like at some
point i'm like joe i just did the same
thing you did to me to joe i'm like
don't you think they can get you don't
you think at some point
we we are blazed i don't mean it i don't
think i don't think joe's like it wasn't
like i'm really thinking like man
they're gonna take him into some room
and be like joe we need you to do this
or that but because i said that
now people like ah duncan called it you
know what i mean and it's like
you know what i mean and and though the
reason they were saying well he called
it is just because joe has a super
popular podcast and people like
when you have a super popular podcast
some percentage of people
watching the podcast are going to be you
know believe things like that they're
going to have a paranoid cognitive bias
that makes them think anybody who is in
the public has been
what's the word for compromised
compromised by the state
look i'll fan the flames of what you
just said with a i went on the cia's
website and i realized that you could
apply for a job on the cia's website
which i found to be hilarious so i'm
like all right what happens if i apply
for a job in the cia now
even then i was not like such an idiot
that
i would want a job at the cia
not just for like ethical considerations
but
i think the skip probably the scariest
part about the cia is like you're just
at a cubicle
and you're like having to deal with maps
and like just you know what i mean just
stuff
lots of paperwork paperwork it sucks i
bet their cafeteria has shitty food
anyone in the cia listening can you
confirm that about the food they're not
gonna be able to tell you what the food
is like i can't even secretive
organization no they might it might be
awesome but we won't know about it okay
we're in vegas yeah and
you can bat
food at the cia cafeteria is good
food at the ca cafeteria sucks
what do you bet not
so let's let's like uh cleanse the
palette what's good it's like you know
silicon valley companies google and so
on that's good when i went to netflix
their cafeteria looked like a medieval
feast like they had pigs with apples in
their mouth and
giant bowls of skittles probably like
vegan pigs yeah
no those are i'm pretty oh i didn't know
i didn't get close enough i was like i
think that was a pig
okay
this is literally a pig
um yeah
yeah you're right you're right i
probably would not bet much money on cia
food being any good right it's it's
gotta suck it's like shitty like pasta
probably like hospital food it's like
maybe a little better than when you go
to the hospital cafeteria but anyway
folks at the cia please uh send me
evidence
uh or any other intelligence agencies if
you would like to recruit some
evidence of better food yes sin lex can
you please send likes pictures of the
cia cafeteria and if you accidentally
send them pictures of the aliens or the
alien technology you have that we won't
tell anybody yeah but the the uh
you tried to apply do you even have a
resume no this yeah i would never
[ __ ] hire me ever but like i applied
for the job and uh just out of curiosity
what happens and then at the end
of the application when you hit enter it
says
well first it says don't tell anyone you
apply for the cia so i'm already out but
the second thing it says is
you don't need to reach out to us we'll
come to you yeah which is really when
you're like it's late at night and
you're being an [ __ ] and applied to
work at the cia it's kind of the last
thing you want to hear
you know you know i don't want to be
secretly approached by some intelligence
officers now anyone who talks to you you
think is a cia's saying remember that
time you applied
oh god yeah yeah sometimes i'm like oh
[ __ ] are you one of them
you and uh joe had a bunch of
conversations
and they're
always incredible thanks so in terms of
this dance of conversation of your
friendship
of when you get together like what is
that world you go to that creates
magic together because we're talking
about how we do that with robots
how do these two biological robots do
that can you introspect that i met joe
because
i was a i was the talent coordinator of
the comedy store this club in la
and my job was to take phone calls from
comics and so
at some point i don't know joe i ended
up on the phone with joe and we just
started talking
and
you know i looked up and like 30 minutes
had passed we just been talking for like
30 minutes that's what our friends are
you know we're just like we're having
fun talking and then he would just call
and we would talk and we would basically
i mean it was no different from the
podcast like we
though the conversations we have on the
podcast are identical to the
conversations we had before he was even
doing a podcast so i think
uh
people are just seeing two friends
hanging out
who like talking to each other yeah but
there's a there's this
weird like you're you you serve as
catalyst for each other to go into some
crazy places
so it's like uh it's a balance of
curiosity and willingness
to not be constrained
uh to not be limited to the constraints
of reality
yeah yeah in your exploration place it's
a very very nice way of saying that
you just like build on top of each other
like uh
you know what if things are like this
and you feel like lego blocks on top of
each other and it just goes to crazy
places adds some drugs into that and
just goes wild yeah and you know he like
it's so cool because it's like uh
you know it's a it's a it's a for me
it's like a really like sometimes maybe
i'll throw something out
that he will take and the lego building
blocks you're talking about they lead to
him saying like the funniest [ __ ] i ever
in my life so it's that's a cool thing
to watch it's just like some idea you've
been kicking around you watch his brain
shift that into like something supremely
funny yeah i really love that man that's
just like a fun thing to like
see happen he knows that i [ __ ] hate
the videos
of animals eating each other like i
don't like that i don't want to watch it
i hate watching it
i don't think i've even articulated on
his podcast how much
i dislike it when he shows animals
eating each other but he knows because
he knows me
and so he he tortures you like when he
starts doing that it's like this kind of
benevolent torture is he like asking
jamie to pull up
increasingly disturbing animal attack
videos so it's just a it's a it's just a
there's a [ __ ] even in torture because
i'm reading about torture in the gulag
archipelago currently there's a bit of a
camaraderie you're in it together
the torture and the tortured what
oh god that's so [ __ ] up man i've
never
no i i mean part of it was joke but as i
was saying it that you're right that
also comes out in the in the book
because they're both [ __ ] they're both
they're both um have no control of their
fate um that same was true in
the camp guards in nazi germany and and
the people in the camps
the worst was brought out in the guards
uh but they were in it together in some
dark way
they're both [ __ ] by a very powerful
system that put them in that place yeah
and both of us could be either player in
that system which is the dark
reality that soldier knits and also
reveals
that uh the line between good and evil
runs to the heart every man as he wrote
in gulag
archipelago
but it is that amidst all that there's a
i don't know the good vibes the
positivity comes out from the both of
you and that's beautiful to see that is
i suppose friendship uh what do you
think makes a good friend
oh god i mean it's a bill you know it's
a billion it's a billion things that
make a good friend but i think you could
break it down to some rgb i think you
can go rgb with like a good friendship
oh in terms of the color the red green
yeah yeah i think you could probably
come up with some like fundamental
qualities of friendship and i'd say
uh
number one it's love like it's
friendship is love it's uh it's a form
of love uh
so
obviously without that i don't know how
you
i mean i'm not saying i think if you're
true friends you love each other so you
need that but love obviously it's not
that's not it that's not enough it's
like
with
uh
true friends have to be like incredibly
honest with each other and not like you
know what i mean but
not like uh
i don't like i think there's a kind of
like i don't know if you've ever noticed
like some people who say you know i just
tell it like it is yeah but the thing
they do those are always the [ __ ]
yeah why is it that your talent like it
is is always negative why is it it's
always cynical or shitty or you're like
nagging somebody or me how come you're
not telling it like it is when it's good
too yeah you know what i mean so we sort
of like trust but
but
a pro evolutionary kind of trust you
know what i mean like you know that
your friend loves you and
wants you to be yourself because if you
weren't yourself then you wouldn't be
their friend you'd be some other thing
but also
they might be seeing your blind spots
that other people in your life your
family your wife whoever might not be
seeing yeah so that's a good friend as
someone who like loves you enough to
when it matters
be like hey
are you all right
and then help you see something you
might not be seeing but hopefully they
only do that once or twice a year you
know yeah yeah but there's something i i
mean it's just
this world especially in if you're a
public figure this this world
has its uh
has
plenty of critics
and it feels like a friend
uh
the criticism part
is already done
for you
i think a good friend is just there to
support
to actually notice the good stuff but in
comedy
we need like that what what like
it's really good in comedy to have
someone you can like be like what do you
think of that
and know that they're not going to be
like that that's for the craft the craft
itself like the work you do not the
uh
yeah
interesting but that's so tough
yeah whatever your particular art form
or whatever you are doing i mean you
don't always be leaning on your friends
opinions for like your own innovation
but it's nice to know that you have
someone who not just with jokes but with
anything if you go to them and run
something by them they're gonna like
they're gonna be honest with you about
like their their real feelings regarding
that thing because that helps you grow
as a person we need that and it hurts
sometimes and we don't want to hurt our
friends one of the more satanic like
impulses when you're with somebody is is
not wanting to
honestly answer whatever they're asking
in that regard or wanting to like put
their temporary feelings over something
that you've recognized is maybe not
great i'm i'm not saying a friendship is
something where you're always critiquing
or evolving each other it's not your
therapist or whatever but it's nice when
it's there you know i think that's
another aspect of
friendship yeah but yeah love is at the
core of that you've noticed i've met
people in my life where almost
immediately sometimes it takes time
where you notice like there's a magic
between the two you like oh [ __ ] you
seem to be made from the same cloth
yeah whatever that is well you know we
have a name for that in the spiritual
community it's called satsang and it's i
love the idea
it's uh
basically like if nietzsche's idea of
infinite recurrence is true
then your satsang would be the people
you've been infinitely recurring
with and those are the people where you
run into them
and you've never met them but it's like
you're picking up a conversation
that
i've never had yeah that uh and that
that you know that is based on an idea
of like this isn't the only life it's we
we're always hanging out together we
always show up together
you've had a brush with death you had
cancer you survived cancer yeah what if
uh how's that change you what what have
you learned about life
about death about yourself
about the whole thing we're going
through here from that experience you
were just in the ukraine yes and you
were making observations on this
what could
if you heard about it and weren't there
seem like it doesn't make any sense at
all which is
people there are
connecting
they've lost everything but they're just
happy to be alive they're happy their
friends are alive so you witness this
like
you know when you get in the cancer club
and you're hanging out with people going
through
cancer who have survived cancer
you see this
beautiful
connection with life that
can can easily sort of you can kind of
lose
that connection with life if you forget
you're going to die forgetting you're
going to die
is or that you can die
is not just i think from an evolutionary
perspective where survival is the game
not not going to improve your survival
chances you know if you think you're
immortal you know but but also
forgetting that you're you're gonna die
and that everything
is around you and everything your your
clothes are probably gonna last longer
than you your your equipment is going to
be around much longer than you you know
like so forgetting these things
um
it can lead you and i know why people
don't want to think about death because
it's scary it's [ __ ] scary it's
terrifying so i get why people don't
want to think about it but the idea is
if i try to pretend i'm not going to die
or just don't think about death or don't
at least address it
then i'll i won't feel scared but it can
have the opposite effect which is you
can end up like
missing a lot of moments you could for
or you you start doing the old kick the
can down the road thing where you're
like
coming up with a variety of ways to
procrastinate
making it work
now
uh because you you know this [ __ ]
human lifespan idea man it's really
caused a lot of problems when they
started saying on average this is how
many years you're gonna live if you're a
human being man
that is like really bad because a lot of
people hear that and they like feel like
that's a guaranteed
number of years in some temporal bank
that you know we're gonna do they have
access to
and when you get cancer
you know that's like when you get the
alert on your phone where you're like
what the [ __ ] wait what
[ __ ]
i like i have like
either i don't know how much money is in
that bank account or i have way less
than i thought
and so
at that point
you get to be in the truth because
that's ultimately i think that that's
what he feels like
it feels like truth it's truth
it's the truth it's the truth like the
whole bubble of ignorance that you
subconsciously built around yourself to
avoid
experiencing the terror of your own
mortality just it's like a meteorite in
the form of your doctor
talking to you just shatters that thing
and now you're like especially with high
testicular cancer so
when you get the diagnosis
um
it's just like the movies they the
mother the doctor took me in his office
and you just know
i got cancer it's like you don't even
have to say it's like i know what you're
about to say i'm in the office i know
how this goes but you you go in there
and what you was you were thinking oh
you know probably i just have some weird
thing in my ball that's why it's swollen
up like that anytime i've gone to the
doctor you always leave like oh cool i'm
fine but no that's not you're gonna
leave the doctor you're gonna leave the
doctor in a completely different
universe than the one you grew up in
you're going to go from talk about
multiverse you just popped into a brand
new multiverse so what was the
conversation with a doctor like was
there like
from a perspective of a doctor
boy is that a hard conversation i feel
like you need to build up
philosophically to that conversation
oh no
oh no there's not time he's busy he's
got other appointments you know also
if you're gonna get cancer testicular
cancer is you know not that there is a
great cancer to get but that's you know
that's a good one because it moves
slowly
uh
the
treatments they have for it are
really advanced now and so if you if you
catch it early
then uh you know generally it's
it's good you can survive it so
so he could offer at least some glimmer
of hope yeah yeah exactly i mean you
know you know but he didn't really do he
couldn't really offer that hope
because
we had to find out how far the cancer
progressed to my body
and that's the next step is like as soon
as they tell you have cancer they don't
they're not they move quick they're like
you know we're going to
schedule the surgery for i think this is
a thursday or friday i feel like we're
going to schedule it for
tuesday
here's the chance here's there he's we
don't know for sure it's cancer that's
what they say it's like there's a 80 or
90 chance
that this is cancer there is some
possibility it could be something else
the only way we can now
is like
doing a biopsy and the only way that we
can get that biopsy is by cutting one of
your balls off he didn't say it like
that but you know that's pretty much the
logic behind it's like we got to get
this thing it's like a zombie bite we
gotta hack this [ __ ] thing off we
gotta do it fast well did did you say it
in the way that you understood yeah what
they do
is because they know that when someone
gets a cancer diagnosis
that
it their ability to comprehend
information changes when you get a
cancer diagnosis
you all the tropes
they happen your hearing gets weird
you're basically having like an anxiety
attack if i had to guess it's like a
hardcore anxiety attack
and then
you know a nurse is there with me as
he's explaining it and then her job is
even though he's telling me how to get
to the machine that's going to scan my
body to see if it's gotten into my brain
uh
he knows i'm not gonna remember that and
so this nurse when you're in this like
fog
takes you
at least took me to the machine that
does the scan but you're not going to
get that data back for a few days
and so that's where you really
live in the real
world
that's the real world such a fascinating
moment and the the days that follow and
even that moment because that doctor you
know you talk about the matrix where
like the pills and so on you get the
bloop
and pill and the red pill yeah
this is like
the
like the real world introduction the the
human introduction is the truth
the you you've now just taken the the
red pill you get to see the the truth of
reality
and here's a busy doctor just telling
you yeah like
all those dreams you've had all those
illusions you've built up to somehow
your work as a comedian and actor will
make you live forever somehow it's just
the basic illusion we have that we're
this is this whole project
uh is gonna be an infinite sequence of
fun things that we're gonna get to do
it's like holy [ __ ] it's not that's
right it's over that's right and there's
very sophisticated ways of doing that
and there's very dumb ways of doing that
and i'd really been doing a dumb way of
doing that like i've been playing around
with this
idiot notion of subjective consciousness
so like like i've been sort of kicking
around this like
i think they call it solipsism it's like
you're like okay i know i'm self-aware
but no one else can prove that they're
self-aware like i don't i have no way of
proving that everything around me isn't
just a video game isn't just some
projection isn't you know who knows what
so maybe
everybody else dies they're nbc's but i
don't because i'm the only thing i know
that has subjective consciousness now
it's not like i really believed that
it's like an idea you toy around with
when you're trying to evade
confronting the reality of your own
mortality it's just the brain will
produce all kinds of ridiculous forms of
ignorance and that was one i've been
playing around with oh you mean for like
a large part of your life you were
playing around with that i'm not like
really i think it's important to really
emphasize i didn't think i was immortal
like i knew at some level i'm probably
gonna die everyone dies yeah but
there's
ways that you can sort of
poke around with that idea i still do it
to this day like i still do it like it's
a natural thing to do when you're
confronted with that with annihilation
you want a way out you want to talk your
way out figure it out there's got to be
some way to fix it well they'll fix it
that's another thing people do oh
they'll fix it yeah it'd be fine they'll
expand the human lifespan that's what
they'll do i mean that was though that's
a big argument for it is like look the
human lifespan up until covid which they
had to recalculate like the
lifespan because of the statistically
all the people who died it like threw it
off a little bit but pandemics aside
the idea was the human lifespan seemed
to be increasing
by half
a year every year something like that we
are living longer
so all you got to do
one more half a year
and we're immortal right if we can if we
live a year longer every year then we
live forever
and so that's another way you can get
out of
confronting death is you can think well
maybe right now we don't have the tech
but it's coming consciousness
uploads
or downloads or whatever depending on
how you want to look at it another way
people try to squirm out of the
reality of
death there's all kinds of tricks yeah
and we do
all of them and sometimes yeah i mean a
lot of religions provide different even
more tools in the toolkit for coming up
with ideas of how you can
live in the illusion that we're not
going to there's not an end to this
particular experience that we're having
here on earth right now and then when
you get that cancer diagnosis
it's like
yeah what was that like uh going home
with the car ride you drive home alone
yeah i mean it was
one of the most would you listen to
bruce springsteen or bruce bracey i
don't know a little girl is your daddy
that's not a good one to listen to you
have cancer is he gonna die
yeah all the love songs maybe you take
you experienced them more intensely
i don't remember what i listened to
and i don't remember driving home
but i do remember driving to another
doctor appointment doctor's appointment
the next day
i think it was the next day
i think the goodyear blimp was floating
in the sky
and i was looking i was a stoplight
looking around is that god
[Music]
is the is the person flying it know how
to cure cancer
oh you were looking
oh wow no i didn't think that what i
thought was
this [ __ ] just keeps going that's what i
thought i thought
i'm going to be gone
and it's just going to keep going
and that was a beautiful moment for me
it was this beautiful moment of life
you're able to accept it oh yeah no like
that's just what you're talking about
with
um the ukraine what you're talking about
it's like
unless you've been been there
it's really hard to explain to people
that even in the midst
of
what is generally accepted is one of the
worst [ __ ] things that could happen
to you war
cancer
somehow
there's still joy there's still love
there's still in fact more it's almost
like when the anesthesia wears off when
you get your mouth worked on you start
feeling again you're feeling you're
noticing and that you know wow but yet
like
thank goodness
i think there's other ways for us to
achieve this state of consciousness
that don't involve war or cancer
you think just meditating meditating
on your mortality is one such mechanism
just simply just
not allowing yourself to uh get lost in
the day-to-day illusion
of life just kind of stopping
putting on bruce springsteen
most spiritual
he is great maybe johnny cash hurt maybe
maybe that one that's good
i am knocking bruce springsteen like i
have a lot of great bruce springsteen
memories truly his music's fantastic
yeah yeah not meditating immortality to
bruce springsteen you know what i'm just
trying to do an audio soundtrack in my
head
i guess we can each have our own audio
soundtrack
i'm on fire it's so good yeah it's a
good one that's one of those at
i laid when the sheets soaking wet and
the freight train running through the
middle of my head
and only you can cool my desire and he's
thinking about someone else's girl yeah
what a [ __ ] nightmare yeah bruce
breinstein's laying in bed with a
freight train running through his head
thinking about banging your wife and
you're out of town yeah oh my god oh
you're taking the other guy's
perspective like holy [ __ ] this guy's
gonna get my wife it's bruce but yeah
you gotta take the other one it's love
it's love both perspectives i'm sure
bruce springsteen thought it was love
when he's sweating in bed waiting to go
to somebody's house and she does too
what does that marry if he's gonna break
up that marriage that marriage wasn't
strong enough right
i mean
that relation i mean that's the way of
love what marriage
could survive
bruce springsteen sweaty bruce
springsteen
uh well maybe one that's based on
financial um
uh sort of financial dynamics versus
like love and sweaty bruce springsteen
like um
like romantic connections because and
there's like a uh
there's a music video of that where he's
like a mechanic i think
yeah so he's like the poor mechanic who
is uh
who falls in love with this girl and
there's that magic
um i've seen that magic you connect with
people like
uh i'll see somebody i think jack
kerouac has that way he meets
uh this mexican girl
on a bus and
like he talks about that heartbreak you
feel when you realize this person you
just fell in love with in a split second
is heading somewhere else in this too
big world
but then he actually realizes in uh
spoiler alert for on the road that
they're actually heading the same way
and he
now builds up the courage to talk to her
and they kind of fall in love for a few
days yeah and then he lies eventually
realizes that
she may not be the perfect person for
him and all the jealousy comes out it's
like why is this beautiful girl
talking to me at all and then she's
probably some kind of i mean that's no
it's not very politically correct but he
basically thinks that she's
a prostitute and he
uh talks to her about like who's your
pimp and all that kind of stuff he
attacks her and all that all that kind
of way when she's just an innocent
right she has you know she has a past of
that kind but she's an innocent person
and he connected and they fell in love
with each other
her gentleness his worldliness all that
kind of stuff um but that sometimes it
doesn't work out that way and there's
that heartbreak when you see you realize
um
you're never going to be able to have
that and that's bruce springsteen saw
that this is a married woman i'm never
going to be able to have that but i want
that and that's the heartbreak i got to
say i just assumed they were [ __ ]
like i didn't right after the song like
the song doesn't get too little girl is
your daddy home did he go away and leave
you all alone
you know he's like
he knows she's at home alone yeah but it
never
materializes
he's he's he's lost it's longing it's a
it's a man who's not with the the thing
he craves for so he's longing for he's
talking about the longing right not with
having hey if anybody in the cia is
watching this can you look into bruce
springsteen's file and let us know if he
actually banged the person
between the song one fact look the
longing though i'll tell you this here's
what's interesting about that thing that
you're talking about
have you ever you've heard have you ever
heard of something called bhakti yoga
i think so yeah it's the yoga of love
and there's all kinds there's forms of
it you the most the one people know
about the most is the hari krishnas but
hari christians are like uh you know the
way in christianity you've got the
episcopalians the catholics the baptist
in bhakta yoga you have various
deities that are the object of
love and so back to yoga is the
is like and what's really cool about
it is it's a
an analysis of love and so and it's the
the
supposition being like love is the way
to
commune with the divine now a
distinction is drawn between
like two big world views that are
spiritual one is
the concept of sort of
unit of consciousness that i you which
you'll you'll run into and a lot of
forms of buddhism if not all a sort of
a way of deconstructing the identity or
understanding that that you might not be
anything at all then in fact you're part
of everything and in that there's a
uh
a potential relief from suffering and
that not just like intellectually
knowing it but
becoming it now um
whereas in
bhakti yoga there's this idea of like
the
the best thing is to be the individual
because
individuals are required for love this
for love to work embodied
love and so
the
quality the thing we call you know the
the experience of love is something that
can be cultivated it doesn't just have
to be for another person it doesn't have
to be for the stranger on the bus it
doesn't have to be for sweaty bruce
springsteen's
lover that you could actually
tr you can actually shift that love to
the divine to god because obviously it's
hard christians it's a theistic religion
they believe in krishna
who is the
from the pov of vaishnava bhakti yoga
the godhead the
source from which everything
uh flows into the into time space so
that
they're all these like fascinating
stories of krishna it's not just most
people are familiar with krishna from
the bhagavad-gita they're about to be
more what's cool about it is because
it's like they're making the oppenheimer
movie and he famously quoted the
bhagavad-gita when the they split the
atom but um
there's all these stories of krishna
that are not just in the
bhagavad-gita
and these stories
they could seem very simple when taken
literally but by schneider back to yoga
it's this very advanced
theistic
yogic system so they take these stories
and from these stories they
extrapolate this incredible analysis of
what love is and how to connect with the
universe so like
krishna has a lover radharani and so
sometimes
they're getting along
sometimes they're fighting
sometimes
they're separated
and so
each of these
ways of feeling about krishna
modes of love
so
longing actually is considered one of
the highest forms of love
the idea is the longing is the grace the
longing is the love so when you find
yourself in a situation
of longing
and heartbreak
it is
identical
to union
you know and perhaps
more intense more intensely
representative of the essence of what is
love yes and and they call it pining so
there's the in it's pining for krishna
and there's also
there's the other ways you could be with
krishna is as a friend so
this is another form of love or
you know as a mother you know uh because
krishna has a
mother so there's like all these ways of
like looking at the various forms of
love and it's a really beautiful
form of yoga that's emphasizing the
individual and then the individual is a
kind of channel to
this universal love yeah they're they
like there's a lot of different like
uh their answer to the question of what
shows up in buddhism is absolute and
relative reality like
that uh obviously there's relative
reality we're we're not right now you
and me are not unitive consciousness
like
you zoom back far enough and we're gonna
seem like an atom or whatever the
the the thing is the trope is or you
could zoom back far enough and we're
gonna whatever we're in a piece of
cheese or something who knows but
in that way we're like completely
unified um but simultaneously we're
individuals like for sure or individuals
like you still gotta pay your taxes you
gotta know your social security number
that's relative reality so you know
buddhism is like kind of the balance
again when i say buddhism is i'm a
comedian podcaster i'm not some buddhist
expert this is just probably my
confused
idea of what it is but anyway in bhakti
yoga there's the concept
it's called i'm going to mispronounce it
a cincinnka beta tatfa
i'm sorry i'm mispronouncing it
which means
simultaneous oneness and difference
so
oneness and difference yes simultaneous
one so that's why the the oneness is the
more
part of the same piece of cheese
and the difference is we are still each
paying taxes
yes and in this case the cheese is
krishna so
you know or other ways it gets
described as like you know a photon
blasting off the sun has sunlight
qualities
but it's not the sun
humans
have being a one of the many things you
know flowing out of the creative
consciousness of the divine
have qualities
that are weirdly like
the god-like you know like we it's in
fact we want to control primarily that's
one of the
problems like humans want to be
in control where and from there the
bhakti yoga perspective
krishna is this effort is effortlessly
controlling
everything
uh and so within the system the
individual parts of the system have that
same quality but you can't you're
probably not god you might be i'm not
uh what do you think happens after we
die
haven't come close to that
that um that cliff
and almost got pushed over once
what do you think happens when you do
get pushed off the cliff
okay i feel dumb that i'm even gonna
like preface this by saying obviously i
have no [ __ ] idea and i think that's
one of the cool things about death
no idea the cia probably does you think
the cia
i love like we've decided your audience
is the cia yeah
how would you oh wait i i need to
because there's a lot of suspicion that
i might be fsb and mossad so i'm trying
to rebrand
i'm trying to steer them into the cia
direction
no as far as what happens when you when
you die
one thing i return to when i'm getting
overly complex
is the idea of as above so below so
uh that you can a lot of the big
questions can be answered by your own
experience
now so
in other words like uh
in terms of thinking about like death
um
if you
look back
to
baby legs
versus adult legs
where's the baby like baby's gone they
you've regenerated all your cells
many times by then so in a way you could
say lex baby died and the death didn't
look like a typical
and i'm not trying to dodge it but i'm
just saying
it was very natural that the death of
that baby it just uh
it just in many ways that baby died but
i am at least personally i'm surprised
how much the person is exactly the same
so there's many ways in which you're
very different
but there's a lot of ways in which
you're very much the same sure and i
wonder if that
if there's if life is defined by many
deaths that contin that continue on and
then there i wonder if there's something
persists sure beyond in this
that
yeah there is something that still
persists i wonder okay so that
now
you know obviously
there's so many different
answers to this question that are
religious and
ranging from like the most absurd [ __ ]
you ever in your life like the gold
you're going to get a mansion there's
gold streets like i don't know do you
even want like gold streets like offers
gold streets i know about the virgins
but there's a bunch of virgins the
christians give you the gold streets in
the mansion like depending on the
and the who whatever the particular sect
of christianity is you know you you it's
like it's some kind of city there's
it's like paved with gold no one's
addressing the fact that the moment the
streets are made of gold gold is a
valueless
substance i mean it's sort of pretty in
a cheesy kind of way but no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] it's like like if there was
not a lot of
asphalt in the world
then you know we'd be in heaven from
that same with that way of thinking but
the
uh or honestly when uh going back this
this this is starting to get a theme
with glug archipelago i'm sorry i'm
reading it currently that's a sticky
book yeah it's very sticky in your mind
very very tough as i'm running through
very hot heat i'm listening to glug
archipelago oh my god and you know one
of the things they said they would feed
the prisoners salt
um
and then they would exchange
the prisoners would be able to
give up anything everything their gold
their possessions everything for just
one drink of water so that little
context of
dehydrating them and feeding them salt
changes your value system completely
right so maybe the gold is supposed to
be a metaphor for something that you
still value deeply yes it's yeah again
any any of these things when you like
take them literally they seem absurd but
if you look deeper into it it's like
quite beautiful but the buddhist version
of it is that uh there's a momentum the
best way to put it is it's a kind of
momentum so
uh the thing you're talking about which
is uh
the personality of the baby that is
still in the adult which is still in the
old person you're looking at a kind of
momentum that does not stop
upon the
extinction of the body
now
the
the
a i think there's a lot of uh
i don't want to say harm because they
didn't mean to hurt but i think there's
some harm that maybe has happened from
the way death
is represented in movies like when
people die in movies it's like
there's this usually it's pretty fast
even if it is uh
what they're dying from is a long-term
disease it like wraps up pretty quickly
starts with a cough the person's in bed
but there's this weird kind of lucidity
to the person up until the point of
death and also they generally in movies
they have makeup on which is always
funny to me when the person dying looks
great if you're ever around a dying
person they're dying they look like [ __ ]
you're dying they're all gray and like
confused they're
you know when you're around dying people
they will spin through time
your parents won't recognize you for a
second they'll think you're somebody
else they won't they're like
everything's
everything's like the process is
happening so
it's a you're very confused when you die
so
in general not all the time some people
die with a with a clear mind it just
depends on the type of death but
think in terms of
uh getting hit by a car so you want to
cross the street you get hit by a car
now
if we're talking about this momentum
continuing
the confusion assuming you didn't hit
your head and you're unconscious like
somehow you just got smashed and you're
like bleeding out
even then you're going to be confused
because you're getting dizzy like
blood's leaving your body you're like
things are fading out your vision's
going so it's a very confusing
experience initially when the body dies
if you are a materialist
who has been
who has convinced themselves that
it's a permanent thing
the next bit of confusion is going to be
when you realize
something is persisting here like i'm
still here and this is where you run
into the near-death experiences which
are a global phenomena that don't seem
to be
completely shaped by culture
you know like regardless of what part of
the world people are having these
experiences in the reports tend to be
similar and everyone's heard it the
light the life review
uh
seeing ancestors and stuff like that now
i don't know what that is
i
don't know i i
sometimes i think that's probably just
like a built-in
way the computer shuts down you know
just this is something it does who knows
but
uh in buddhism the concept is
this momentum persists into something
called the bardo the bardo means in
between and um
there's an actual number of days they
say that
you get to hang out there and i can't
remember it's like 37 days or 29 days or
something i'm not sure but
at least from the
time space perspective that's how long
they're there
within this place
uh
it's there are a lot of technological
parallels man it's like
in the way the algorithm
is reflective it assesses your desires
or whatever and then produces something
that is
has within it a component of attraction
to you apparently this happens in the
bardo like or the way you know you wake
up in the morning
and
you're in a shitty mood
and then coincidentally everyone that
day is an [ __ ]
if you don't catch it you could just be
like wow i guess it's act like an
[ __ ] day you don't realize you're
seeing your [ __ ] projection
like being reflected off the screen of
another person so in the bardo
apparently you don't need people for the
reflective quality
these projections happen and there they
appear as either
nietzsche's demon or nietzsche's angel
it just depends on
where you're at and how you died and
like if you died scared
then at least initially that's gonna be
some scary [ __ ] you see around you if
you died in a peaceful way well then
uh
there's going to be more of a
possibility of navigation through this
liminal intermediary
place and so thus the emphasis on
meditation in buddhism a way to
calm one's self to not be distracted by
thoughts which are their own like
apparitions
and then
theoretically if you wanted to
instead of
spinning the wheel again and jumping
back into a body
you could choose not to do that and then
you know transcend the wheel of birth
and death but if you still wanted to go
back
or
return or whatever however you want to
put it then you could have more control
over what your next birth might be
versus
in this depiction of things people
running from
demons that they don't recognize as
their own projection
into any [ __ ] body that they can find
because if you've had a body you want a
body and so this is how you can
incarnate as an animal this is how you
can incarnate in the hell realms this is
how you could incarnate in any variety
of things but the idea is like maybe you
could slow down a little bit and like
choose a birth that is going to be more
conducive to you
uh
continuing to like
spiritually evolve i like that idea is
it true or not who the [ __ ] does
algorithmically speaking it it seems
like a really fun role-playing game
where you basically oh yeah keep
improving the different parameters
based on your
ability and willingness to
meditate and
let go of the
of the
menial concerns of life on earth yeah
why do you think
buddha see life is suffering
what's suffering okay well first of all
the
that is that gets mistranslated quite a
bit you're talking about the four noble
truths the first one is it often gets
translated as life is suffering which is
not
it it's there is suffering the whole
life is suffering thing is just like the
spiritual version of life's a [ __ ] then
you die and people hear that they're
like yeah life is [ __ ] suffering but
it's there is suffering there is
suffering so
it's an affirmation
if you're like this this thing that a
lot of people feel that they associate
with lots of they have a lot of reasons
they think they're feeling it
is known as fundamental dissatisfaction
so so
another word for suffering maybe could
be
fundamental dissatisfaction also
the term itself
uh
maybe a better translation is wobbly
wheel
so like imagine like when your bike
doesn't have an or your car doesn't have
enough air in the tires your bike
doesn't have air in the tires it's kind
of a shitty bike ride like no matter
what just kind of like it's like
uncomfortable it's like irritating so
this is
what's being pointed to is that there's
this quality
within a human life
that is
um
unsatisfying like like a wobbly wheel
wobbly wheel why do you what why do you
think
what is at the core of that
dissatisfaction
because it could be uh it could be as
simple as kind of physical and mental
discomforts and
sadness and depression and all that kind
of stuff yeah or it could be more
speaking to the sort of existentialist
the philosophical
the absurdity of it all yep the fact
that stuff happens good stuff happens
for no reason bad stuff happens for no
reason yeah um yeah that it's
no matter how much you try
there's not
a universal fairness to the whole thing
there's not even a universal meaning to
the whole thing
so the existentialist perspective what
do you what what flavor of suffering do
you prefer oh it was an ice cream shop
ah that's so funny well i'm gonna i'm
definitely picking desire over the like
if
in in the rgb that we're talking about
here is
desire
aversion
and ignorance so if you want to find
like the three
uh the the three ingredients that are
giving everyone their sophisticated
bits of suffering there you go that's
what what's uh in which way does design
manifest itself in suffering it hurts
to lose to not have
like yeah it hurts to not like to
eternally not have but just like
my friend pointed this out he's like you
know like
you order something from amazon like
even in the smallest way you're excited
about whatever the thing is you order
this thing from amazon it's not coming
for four days so those four days are
going to be somewhat marked by you being
what people say i'm excited about it
but really if you look at that feeling
it's uncomfortable like the feeling of
wanting the thing is uncomfortable
so
that is a form of suffering that's
suffering
interesting i mean i wonder
because we naturally reframe that in our
mind
wanting
we reframe that as a good thing as um
and maybe suffering is
fundamentally good
in the way we think of what life is
like it's life affirming
but it's not usually how the word
suffering is used well it's true
it's true like the first noble truth of
buddhism is true it's called the truth
of suffering there is suffering i mean
this is like an i don't know an element
that you can't break it down any further
than that like there is suffering this
is truth so
if you think
you know and again as signing like good
or bad to truth i think maybe
there's more of a sort of neutrality
there it's just what it is it's truth i
mean is it any is it basically is
suffering any disturbance
uh from stillness
is suffering then
like basically any
anything that happens in life that
uh
that's like that perturbs the system
ripples in the end ripples ripples yeah
so a still lake is is empty of suffering
but any kind of ripple is is suffering
in that sense a still lake is empty of
suffering
you sound like a zen master it seems
like something is in masturbation if i
can just grow a beard like yours ah i
know the beard doesn't help
if i had your chin you think i'd have a
[ __ ] beard i look like a stork you
should see me if i had your chin there
would be no beard here no you have a
symmetrical nice chin this is the
closest i can come to plastic surgery
pubic plastic surgery friend
that's how you know you're a
professional comedian
uh
yes it's suffering they're suffering
and
the lake
analogy is pretty good because
the um
what's happening here is that that
we have become
identified with something that we call a
self so
this the self is just accepted i have a
self i have an identity i'm a person i
have a self
but
when you
start doing scans to try to find
yourself which is the entire thing i'm
going to find
myself you get in a van go to california
take some acid yeah [ __ ] a prostitute on
the bus or whatever kerouac did i'm
gonna find myself she didn't
he she wasn't a prostitute just to
correct the record oh previously
prostituted i guess once a prostitute
was a prostitute you know what she's a
former i don't think that no and look
i'm not i've
not assigned it look all i'm saying is
uh i don't care who cares who has a bit
of prostitute god you are used to be one
we're all obviously we're all kind of a
kind of prostitute yeah yes yes but the
the i make love
and we make money
therefore we're all a kind of prostitute
we make god how great i would really
love to be able to make money by [ __ ]
i mean it's maybe not directly but in
some sense directly
[Laughter]
do you accept venmo
never too late to start that's so sort
of one of the ways in is this sort of
contemplation of
the identity because it's like
uh
you know what it's it's not just the
desire it's what is having the desire
where does the desire live in like what
doesn't want to be where it's at what is
the thing that is like
desperately wanting to get out of the
situation it's in and then um as far as
ignorance uh it's still something that's
theoretically happening to an identity
so
so wrapped up in it is really just this
sort of like and that's where we run
into what
into attachment so if
if the first noble truth of buddhism is
there is suffering
the second noble truth of buddhism is
um the cause
of
this suffering is attachment and so
people hear that and they take it that's
a there's a lot of levels to that
concept definitely the cause of
suffering is attachment i mean god i
just got addicted to vapes is there a
more embarrassing
addiction than vapes i'm smoking like a
little purple thing it tastes like sugar
it's attachment it is there is suffering
i want it i have to charge it now i'm
embarrassed by it makes me feel out of
control there's a lot of suffering but
also
there's deeper levels of attachment they
go all the way to this
attachment to the sense of
one's
self and the i think the existentialists
do get into this idea in a different way
which is like
because i think i'm a me
now i have to push
what that thing is out into the world
through my actions and that's a kind of
attachment too
exactly there you go right and that
leads to the third noble truth which is
get rid of attachment
and you won't suffer anymore
uh
that's it seems logical but you know it
is a very
it is a mathematical analysis of
uh this particular problem of suffering
it's addressing and then the fourth
noble truth is the eightfold path of
buddhism which is like a
a process by which one could
unencumber
oneself from this identification with
something that isn't real
do you have a bathroom break
yeah thank you i do
appreciate that
there's a funny moment i was running in
the heat yesterday listening to
gulag archipelago
and uh there's a which was a very
welcome break because i'm looking for
any excuse to stop whatsoever
uh the
gentleman very nice gentleman stopped me
saying recognize me just said a bunch of
friendly things
and then he
mentioned as as one of the people who
really inspires him is
duncan trussell
you know
and now i was uh i mean i'm the same way
and i told them you know tomorrow it
felt like a name drop
i named you this morning
i was like tomorrow i'm gonna get to
meet him so he says he says hi and
there's oh and he said that um
he watched midnight gospel on
on mushrooms and it was like the
greatest mushroom experience of his life
i don't know
yeah man i yeah i was nervous about
meeting you man like i have so much
respect for you and like oh yeah i name
dropped i was saying i'm going on alex's
podcast today it's you look we're so
lucky we all live here what the [ __ ]
we're all living in austin together like
i i
somehow like missed that
but
that's we all got to hang out we all
have to like start doing stuff but you
have to really also you have to
appreciate this moment i
i remember uh i i know
some people are less amount and
sentimental than others
but i remember sitting with um
with joe rogan
and with eric weinstein i believe it was
yeah and at the back of the comedy store
um shortly before covet i think
and just thinking like there's no way
these things will last
and these things meaning the comedy
store
joe rogan
yeah joe rogan d joe rogan like a pot
like a pocket influential podcasting
person yeah also
uh a person
like in this room in this space the
ability to just talk for hours and lose
ourselves in this moment it just felt um
ephemeral somehow
temporary and i just wanted to capture
that moment somehow like yeah i don't
know sometimes that's where the
temptation to take a picture and that
kind of stuff or record a podcast comes
from right but just felt like it would
be it'd be gone forever
of course uh joe doesn't seem to have
that kind of sentiment
no no no just wherever you end up you
just enjoy the [ __ ] out of it right
that's it well and that's something you
have to cultivate you know that's not an
easy the thing you're talking about you
know uh
god have you seen these
uh i think the best analogy for you're
talking about there's these videos where
people give like a sugar cube to a
raccoon
but the raccoons they wash their food so
raccoon or i think it's cotton candy
they give the raccoon cotton candy
immediately it washes the cotton candy
and of course the cotton candy dissolves
in the water and the raccoon is like
what the [ __ ] like you know and and the
thing you're that grasping you're
talking about it's like the raccoon
washing the cotton candy like the moment
you get into the grasping part
you
paradoxically have pulled yourself out
of the moment that inspired the grasping
part
and and that's you know that's some
people that's the entirety of their
lives
trying to record i mean jesus man you
ever see people film fireworks on the
fourth of july with their phone it's one
of the most remarkable
qual
aspects of human behavior which is like
you know they're not gonna watch
the fireworks
on their phone
only a lunatic would do that like who's
gonna go back and look at fireworks but
but we're also in this position where
because of podcasting there is some
aspect where you can record a magical
moment in time
together between two people
or even just with the camera so to get
back to the lake
that you were talking about this is
emptiness so that's emptiness that's
what's known as emptiness the lake is
emptiness and that's what we are
emptiness emptiness and that's another
thing that gets very confused in in in
buddhism is that
emptiness and that emptiness
is that's to me like when i'm
going to do a podcast that's where i try
to go i try to go just in the moment
no agenda you know if i am nervous or
whatever okay i'll feel the nervousness
but just in the just drop into the
moment that's when time change time
changes and then you look up
hours have passed it feels like a second
and the reason it feels like that is
because if you
uh successfully dropped into the moment
it's
it's the lake now it's emptiness it's
forever for a second you're like dim
you're dipping into eternity and
and yeah it's a it's a very strange
thing to to as part of that record it
you know it's part of that try to like
grab it and and put it out there but it
works
can you speak to that to uh the duncan
trussell family hour can you speak about
that purple lavender world you go to
when it's most intense and successful
for you when you feel a sense of
lightness and happiness when it when it
works yeah whether it's your own or a
conversation with joe in general whereas
uh well yours is very specific because
it's audio only maybe you can also speak
to that yes
you might as well be
naked or you don't have to yeah you have
to you're free of the conventions yes of
the the real world
i will never stop
thinking it's remarkable like the fact
that i'm talking to you to me
seems remarkable not just
technologically but i'm talking to
someone
i'm assuming i'm allowed to say this who
has robot
dogs that i've been watching
for years evolve on youtube i'm
arms reach away from one of these things
you know and i'm i'm with somebody who
is like an acclaimed genius so for me
it's like oh my god how's
what why do i get to have this
conversation why do i get to be here
when there would be like a line there'd
be a line that were just wrapped and
wrapped and wrapped around this building
and people would love a chance to just
chat with you and so when i with my
podcast
that is how i feel like when i'm talking
to these guests you know who have
spent you know some of them have like
spent their entire lifetime
meditating
you know studying specific
uh aspects of buddhism or or even when
i'm with you know with when i'm with
comedians who who i like
consider to be brilliantly funny so for
me it's just like
god i almost feel like
i've just created some sophisticated
trap for cool people where like i get to
like hang out with him so you're like
sitting in the gratitude of it just just
feeling lucky yeah yeah feeling lucky
and wrestling with imposter syndrome you
know trying to like get that part of
myself to shut up long enough so i could
be in that moment that we're talking
about you know
and and then and then i carry that with
me it's not just like you stop the
podcast it's like some of the things
these people tell me
or some of the ways they are like it
becomes part of me and then i get to
have a life where this thing that they
gave me is in in me forever and so yeah
it's uh it's there's yeah it's cool how
conversation can just
a few sentences
can change the direction of your life if
you're listening if you're there to be
transformed by the words they will do
the work yes
um and it's the full mix of it it's
usually
when um if you look up to somebody
and it's true for me at least i think it
is for you that you start to look up to
basically everybody you talk to yes
yes good sign yeah that's a good sign
god forbid it goes the other way yeah
you're in trouble yeah if all of a
sudden you start looking down on people
because whatever crazy metric you're
using
oh that would freak me out i do feel
like that's the quality of getting older
when i was younger i really like i
i thought it was so smart like i thought
i all figured out oh really so you're
going you're your ego is just going
taking the nosedive i would like to say
it's my ego taking a nosedive i've me
and my friend talk about it a bunch
we've just always associated it with
like doing
acid for
two decades straight like i'm gonna just
assume i'm just like
slowly like spiraling into senility you
know like i'm just like i i
all the confidence all the like oh the
certainty when you're having like in
college having the great yeah oh like
like you know you i remember you're
you feel like you're a representative of
camus or some [ __ ] you know what i mean
you read the myth of sisyphus and now
you like it know all existentialism and
your certainty in regards to it is
embarrassing but you don't see it in
that way you just feel certain and then
that certainty it just starts like
it starts crumbling a little bit and
then
yeah you know i get to actually
intensely experience
that certainty in many communities but
one in in cryptocurrency
young folks
with the certainty that this technology
would transform the world yeah and i
mean this is almost one of the big
communities of the modern era
where they believe that this will really
solve so many of the problems of the
world they believe in it very intensely
and
aside from the technology and the
details of the thing all i see is the
certainty and the passion in their eyes
they'll stop me let me
uh let me explain you let me let me just
give me a chance to tell you why this
thing is extremely powerful and i i just
get to enjoy the glow of that because
it's like yeah wow this i i miss having
that certainty about anything yeah it's
probably come over for me too
yeah but when i was younger it's like
only
i deeply understand the
the relationship of man
to his mortality yeah and i understood
that most deeply i think when i was like
16 or 17. and i have i am the
representative of the human condition
and all these adults
with their busyness day-to-day life and
their concerns they don't deeply
understand right what i understand which
is the only thing that matters
is uh
the absurdity of the human condition
yeah
yeah and and let me quote you some dusty
husky oh boy and you speak russian yes
you've read the brothers karamazov in
russian unfortunately i have to admit
that
um
i read all of these in english
i
came to this country when i was 13
and at least don't remember we read a
lot but we read
tolstoy pushkin
a lot of the russian literature but it
was it in russian but i don't remember
reading dusties i wonder which point
does the russian education system give
you dostoevsky because it's pretty heavy
stuff in second grade
that's right the second grade russians
are intense i don't remember yes they
they are they're very they very much are
i don't remember reading this but i did
uh
tangent upon a tangent upon a tangent i
traveled to paris recently on the way to
ukraine
and uh was
scheduled to talk to richard piver and
oliver say this pair the translate
dostoevsky
uh tolstoy just this famous pair that
translate most of russian literature to
english and i i was
planning to have a sequence of
you know five ten fifteen hour
conversation with them about the
different details of all the
translations and so on um i just found
myself in a very dark place mentally
where i couldn't think about podcasts or
anything like that it caught me off
guard
so i went to paris and just laid there
for a day
not just being stressed about
ukraine and all those kinds of things
yeah but i'm still
the the act of translation is such a
fascinating
way to approach some of the deepest
questions that this literature raises
which is like how do i capture the
essence of a sentence that has so much
power and translate it into another
language right that act is actually
really really interesting and there
i found with my conversations with them
they
they've really thought through this
stuff it's not just about language it's
about the ideas in those books right and
that's um that that also really makes me
sad because i wonder how much is lost in
translation i'm currently
so when i was in ukraine
i talked to a lot of
like half the conversations i had
on the record were in russian
and
basically
a hundred percent off the record were in
in russian versus in in english
and uh just so much is lost in those
languages and i'm now struggling
because i'm uh launching a russian
channel or
there would be a russian overdub of
duncan wow
your wow will now be translated into
russian what's russian wow
i don't that it'll just be wow probably
i'm so sorry for the for the
difficulties of having to translate wow
usually probably with wow they'll leave
it unoverdubbed because people
understand exactly what you mean but
that's an art form and it's a weird art
form yeah it's like how do you capture
the
the chemistry
the excitement the
yeah
i don't know maybe
the the humor
the implied kind of wit i don't know
there's just layers of complexity in
language that you it's very difficult to
capture yeah and i wonder how
it is sad for me because i know russian
how much is lost in translation and the
same
you know there's a brewing conflict and
tension with china now and so much is
lost in the translation between those
languages oh my god yeah in cultures the
entire
the the music of the people is
completely lost because we don't know
the language or most of us don't know
yeah how much of the conflict is just
problems in translation how much of the
all these problems that we're having are
just the alien sense of this or that
it's just as simple as that
words are getting
just that just the a a tiny
warp
away from the intent
of if when we both speak the same
language
we can still
say something that offends someone when
you never intended that at all
how much more so
when
like it's not only is it a completely
different sound but the script itself is
different like
uh what is
the russian writing is it called cyril
cyrillic or what's that yes or like
certainly
and i don't know the name for chinese
writing but it's like like it's a
continuum that like gets weirder and
weirder looking you know like
it's so yeah or less weird depending on
your perspective yeah
i'm sure depending on where you're at
you know i'm definitely i'm about the
farthest thing from a polyglot as there
could be man like but i'll tell you
at one point when i was getting
fascinated by
dostoevsky i did have this very
transient fantasy about learning russian
so that i could like understand
the difference in and you were you were
17 18 at the time good college yeah yeah
brothers karamazov lost in that book
just like oh god
so
in love with it
but there's a there is definitely
like um you know ukraine and that's what
they're a lot of the war is about is
saying you know ukraine and russia are
not
the same people there's a strong culture
in ukraine there's a strong culture in
russia but you know i know because
that's where my family is from there is
a fascinating
strong culture
but there's such strong cultures
everywhere else too
ireland has a culture scotland as a
culture yeah even like a on a tiny
island you have these like subcultures
that are
more powerful than anything existed in
human history
like the bronx i don't know like
like different parts of new york have a
certain culture and then new york versus
l.a versus well and then certain places
are looking for their culture like i
don't i think austin
i don't know what austin is i don't
think anyone knows there's a
there's a traditional austin and then
it's evolving constantly same with
boston a place i spent a lot of right
there's a traditional boston and now
it's evolving with the different yeah uh
younger people coming from the
university and staying and all that is
evolving but underneath it there's a
core like the american ideal of the the
value of the individual the value of
freedom
of freedom of speech all those kinds of
things that permeates all of that and
the same thing in
uh the the history of world war ii
permeates ukraine and russia
a lot of parts of europe the memories of
all that suffering destruction yeah the
broken promises of governments and the
uh
the occupier versus the
the liberator all that kind of stuff all
that permeates the culture that affects
how cynical or optimistic you are
or
how much you appreciate
material possessions versus human
connection right all that kind of stuff
yeah it's i mean this is like you talk
about absurdity i mean this is what war
is like it's the what absurdity looks
like it's it's
some kind of organized madness none of
it makes sense like all of it like it's
just
none of it makes sense like
but it does but it doesn't i mean
obviously you're defending yourself or
you're
taking orders that if you don't take
you're you're going to jail and so
or some somewhere in between you know
the classic story about this maybe it's
a [ __ ] myth about world war ii
you've i'm sure everyone's heard it
because it comes up you know it's
christmas eve
and they
have a ceasefire
and then i think they played soccer
they sing christmas songs and then they
had to force them into fighting again
yeah and and so when those moments
happen
the uh are you familiar with hakeem bay
he's a controversial figure sadly like
he like i think he was like
with i'm not gonna defame him because i
haven't like researched it correctly but
some people have said [ __ ] but since i
don't know the reference i'm not gonna
but regardless
um i mean you know look i'm sorry but
bill cosby was funny you know like
that's a
that's a funny comedian but
you know the other stuff michael jackson
he could [ __ ] dance
and sing and sing but there's some other
stuff but regardless um hakeem bay came
up with the idea of something called a
temporary autonomous zone
which is that within a s
structure a cultural structure
a temporary
bubble of
freedom will appear
that by
its nature
gets sort of
popped by the bigger
bubble or it runs out of resources
generally is what happens so
these things will appear just out of the
blue that
it's almost like
imagine if like on earth in some tiny
little bit of earth the gravitational
field was reduced by
some percentage and all of a sudden you
could jump really high or whatever but
it wouldn't last it's like that
culturally all the restrictions and the
darkness and the heaviness and all of it
for a second
somehow this bubble appears where humans
come together
as the
hippie ideal
brothers sisters just humans
earthlings instead of
american chinese russian ukrainian
temporary autonomous zone it gets
crushed by the default reality that it
was appearing in but somehow within that
space
you witness
the possibility
the possibility the frustrating
possibility that
anyone who's thought about
humanity has knows this possibility
which is like it seems like we can just
get along
like it does seem like we're pretty much
the same thing and then we can just get
along
um those moments are really rare
it's sad so i talked to a lot of
soldiers a lot of people that were
suffered through the different aspects
of that
war
and
there is an information war that
convinces each side that
the other is not just the enemy but less
than human
right
so
there's a real hatred towards the other
side yeah
and those kind of little moments where
you realize oh
they're human like me yeah and not just
like human like me but they're they have
the same values as me
and um
uh this this woman
who was a really respected soldier she
specializes in anti-and tank missiles
and
she she's very kind of very pragmatic
very
the enemy is the enemy who have to
destroy the enemy and saying like
there's no compassion towards the enemy
they're not they're not human they're
less than human
but she said there was there was a
moment when
she remembers an enemy soldier
in a tank
took a risk to save a fellow soldier
and that risk was really stupid because
he was facing he was going to get
destroyed
and then she she said that
um she tried to shoot a rocket at that
tank and she missed
and then she later went home and she
couldn't sleep that she missed how could
she screw that up
but then she realized that
actually
she missed maybe she missed on purpose
yeah
because
she realized that that man
just like she is
was a hero
just like she strives to be
they were both heroes defending their
own
and in that way he was just like her she
was like that's the only time i remember
during this war ever feeling
like this is another human being but
that was a very brief moment yeah
and i just hear that over and over and
over again these romantic notions we
have
of
we're one
that we're all just human
unfortunately during war
those notions are rare
and it's quite sad and worn in a certain
way really destroys those notions and
one of the saddest things
is it just it destroys it
at least from what i see
potentially for generations oh yeah not
just for those people for the rest of
their life but for
their children their children's children
the hatred
i mean i asked that question of
basically everyone which is um
will you ever forgive for asking of
ukrainians will you ever forgive the
russians
will um do you have hate in your heart
towards the russians
or do you have
love
for a fellow human being
and
there's different
ways that people struggle with that
different people they saw that
they they saw the love they saw the hate
with their known heart
and they struggle with the hate they
have and they know they can overcome it
in a period of weeks and months after
the war is over but some people said no
this hate that was
that showed up in in february when the
war started will be with me forever well
yeah their kids got killed
what the [ __ ] you gonna do about that
like i don't care i don't i've got you
know i've got aphorisms and cute little
stories about you know you're still in
prison if you hate your former captors
but man i gotta tell you
if somebody hurt my kids
i'm not coming back i mean
there's no amount
at least right now in my approximation
of spiritual literature
meditation or anything that i can really
think of that is going to
give me that kind of space like i i like
i think i imagine in the same way like
uh
i imagine i could probably run a
marathon eventually but do i think i
don't think i'm ever going to do that
that times a million so man
you know all we can do is have
compassion for their hate because it's
like
what are you gonna tell what are you
gonna say what are you gonna say to
someone like that oh
oh you know
for the sake of humanity
let it go it was just your kids it was
just something you loved more than
anything in the world you'll never be
okay again you'd have nightmares for the
rest of your life
but you should forgive
no well there is truth in the fact that
forgiveness is the way to let go right
but that truth is not that you
uh [ __ ] you right this is um which is
why it's not your job to say that you
know and i'm not that you're doing that
i know you're not but you know the
problem with people like me
early phase you could get this stupid
missionary thing going where you like
start trying to like
uh
i don't know like proselytize ideals
that you might be incapable of you know
and i i just
hearing it you know i that's the
man i saw this uh
the thing that like i mean i've seen a
lot all of us have by now probably if or
online i've seen and you just saw it in
person like we've seen things that are
just
horrific
but as a dad
man i just saw this clip of this kid
around the age of my kid
walking
by himself these refugees just walking
by himself
chron the look on his face i can't
explain the look on his face
i don't know what happened to his
parents i don't know what happened like
i
it was so upsetting i like even thinking
about now it's just like [ __ ] that could
have been my kid that could have been my
kid you know so
knowing that kind that
that kid's got to grow up
now that and i don't know does it is the
kids parents still there and that's just
one
of
countless
orphans out there now so what you have
this
hate and the question is how to direct
it
because the choice is you can direct it
towards the politicians that started the
war
you can direct it towards the soldiers
that are doing the killing or you can
direct it towards an entire group of
people
and that's the struggle because hate
slowly grows to where you don't just
hate
the soldiers you don't just hate
the the leaders
you hate all russians
because they're all equally evil because
the ones that aren't doing the fighting
are staying quiet
and i'm sure the same kind of stories
are happening on the other side
and so
there is
that hate
is uh one
that
is is deeply human
but you wonder
for your own future for your own home
for building your own community for
building your own country
how does that hate morph over the
weeks and months and years
not into forgiveness but into something
that's productive that doesn't destroy
you because hate does destroy that's the
dark aspect of uh
you know a rocket that heals hits a
building and kills
hundreds of people
the worst effect of that rocket
is
is the hate in the hearts of the loved
ones
to the people that were in that building
yes that hate is this is a torture over
a period of
years after and that it doesn't just
torture
uh by having that psychological burden
and trauma it also tortures because it
destroys your life
it prevents you from being able to enjoy
your life to the to the fullest right it
prevents you from
being able to flourish as a human being
as a as a professional as a you know
in all those kinds of ways that humans
can flourish and
i i don't know and it's such a um you
know there is there is a
there is an aspect where this naive
notion
is really powerful that love and
forgiveness is the thing yeah that's
needed in this time and and um
when i talk to soldiers they don't
you know i remember bringing up to uh to
jocko
is there a sense where the people you're
fighting are just brothers in arms
bringing up the dire straight song
brothers in arms
and he was basically without swearing
saying [ __ ] that that they're the enemy
yeah i mean he's literally in survival
mode yeah he can't think like that it's
going to create latency in the system
and that's going to lower survivability
you can't think that i mean we're
talking about like cognitively you can't
have latency like if you're that one
moment of hesitation like you see it
sometimes like in these youtube videos
of uh
like um
somebody
a a a new cop
has
been unfortunate enough to run into
something that is a phenomena suicide by
cop
somebody has a knife and that person is
running towards them with a knife and
they're begging the person to stop that
you can hear it in their voice they're
begging stop stop stop stop and the
person is not going to stop
so
the critique of that
is that
that
latency
could potentially not just lead to the
cop getting
killed but to that person
with a knife killing other people and so
you know
i get i i if i were out there i think
that like
you
you want you probably just as a matter
of like
not getting shot and being fully in the
moment you have to be like that i would
guess i don't know i don't know i'm the
furthest thing from a soldier there
could be but
there's a
something jack cornfield this great
buddhist teacher says which is
tend to the part of the garden you can
touch
meaning this is where we're at right now
thank god you and i
though we are experiencing some like
ripples from what's going on over there
everyone is
we're not there and thank god we don't
have to come up with the
psychological
program for
people going through that to no longer
be encumbered by that hate thank god and
i don't know if that's just lazy or
whatever but it's like you know for me i
just i have to bring it back to all
right well here's where i'm at now
and
uh
i i don't i like i don't want there to
be war
i don't want to hurt people but yeah i
love what you said i think what you said
is the
if anything is the most
intelligent way of looking at it it's
like don't pretend that you're not gonna
feel that hate like
you're gonna feel it there's no way
around or like because that's even worse
because then you're almost saying like
something's wrong with them for feeling
the hate or you know whatever but more
along the lines if you can avoid
applying that hate
to
an entire country of people
then
do that like just understand we're
talking about like uh
not everybody i know it's not everybody
i know it's not everybody it's just
easier isn't it cognitively it's somehow
easier to think
all russians
monsters
you know all russians
all whatever the particular like thing
is that you're supposed to not like it's
easier somehow weirdly you'd think
that'd be more difficult
yeah but
i guess the lesson is uh
if you give in to the easy solution
that's going to uh lead to detrimental
long-term effects
so yeah hate should be
um it's such a powerful tool
that you should try to control it
for for your own sake not because you
owe anything to anybody right for your
own right for your own psychological
development over time right right that's
it
that's it
[ __ ]
yeah
yeah
uh in terms of dark places um you
suffered from depression
war has been some of the darker places
you've gone in your in your mind
you know i needed therapy man i needed
therapy for the longest time i just
didn't get it and i uh
so because of that i
uh
i would go through
like bouts of like
paralytic depression
like suicidal depression suicidal
ideations that were more than just
ideations i mean i think like
people get afraid when the thought of
suicide appears
in their consciousness they get really
scared of themselves so they think
there's something like
[ __ ] what's going on with me why would i
think that but i think if we are
suffering and you know as a natural part
of not of wanting to reduce suffering or
not feel bad anymore
i mean
suicide is going to be a not like if
we're just you know you're just looking
what are all the options let's
brainstorm here
you know what i mean i can start
drinking more water
i can start jogging get some therapy
call my friends all the stuff we all
hear or i could just
i think the height of my apartment
building is probably the definitely the
right height to kill myself and then you
and then
so where
for me like the few times where the
ideation has gone towards like
well when would i do that
how do i what you know what do i need to
like
accomplish that when then like that's
where it gets really [ __ ] scary
that's where it's like terrifying so you
start the actual
details of the planning of how to commit
suicide yeah
what's going to be the least painful way
to do it what's going to be the most
instantaneous way to do it what's the
you know and with you know with
depression because it it can be
progressive
you know this is why
you have to really just stay on top of
anyone who's gone through depression
knows what i'm talking about you got to
stay on top of it like you might need
medication you know i know this is
controversial now but it's still better
than dying if you ask me but at some
point with depression
it like becomes paralyzing so you don't
want to get out of bed anymore and
you're not taking showers anymore and
you don't want to talk to anybody
anymore and you're not answering your
phone anymore and
you know
so like in a dark place that you might
be in
it still might get worse so you should
really yes do everything you can
to immediately control you and that's
the problem with that specific
psychological disorder
that's the problem because it the things
it's like if you start listening to what
you wanted you think it's you it's the
depression you start listening to it
it wants you to stay in bed it's and
then you're getting those [ __ ]
depression sleeps
you know or you wake up and you're more
tired like it's not working you're
trying to escape reality by sleeping and
and and so
yeah like you have to like
you're it's you're fighting for your
you're literally fighting for your life
it might not seem like that because you
can't if you could see depression if you
could see it if you knew you had some
inky
vaporous
octopus thing that was just wrapping
around you more and more and more and
more you would probably do everything
you could to rip that [ __ ] thing off
your body and if you couldn't get it off
your body you would
be calling people to get help so it
doesn't feel like a fight because you're
exhausted there's no reason to move
there's no you don't see the meaning for
any of it so it doesn't feel like a
battle but it is a battle you're not
feeling i mean that's the other thing
you're just you're basically not feeling
you're like you you start going numb at
least that was my experience with it
numb and tired and then
increasingly numb and tired and then
increasingly sort of disconnecting from
reality and then somewhere in there
that's when you start playing around
with the idea
of like i don't know if it's worth it i
don't know now you know i think compared
to some of my friends who haven't
survived obviously who haven't survived
depression like mine was definitely not
whatever theirs was like it i've heard
uh
i mean to understand it for folks out
there maybe you haven't gone through it
just imagine
if like how bad you have to feel if
death is the salute like
like violence against yourself so that
you die is the solution like just
it flies in the face of everything
so i i would yeah that was definitely
the darkest
place that i've ever been is it just
that death doesn't seem like
because you don't care about anything
anymore that death just doesn't seem
like that bad yeah
um
like you're not able to appropriately
assign
the negative cost to this the solution
right just seems like a reasonable
solution yeah and but in in in and but i
think also what's going along with it is
like
it's not like your your brain isn't
working like you're you're you're not
thinking you're obviously you're not
thinking clearly like
at least again this is was my experience
of it it's a fog you're in some kind of
like you're confused there's confusion
there's shame
you feel embarrassed you feel
embarrassed you want to get out of bed
you want to do stuff you want to be
compelled to be social and do all this
stuff but you're not you're not and like
you seem if people don't know what's
going on and you're not telling them
because you're embarrassed
because you you want like you want to
have some like
you know
uncorrupted
un
warped psyche
you know you're like it invites you to
be secret about it that's one of its
first tricks is it tells you not to tell
anybody and and that's deadly with in in
that case is deadly what was the source
of light what was the
what were for you
and in general the ways out
yeah
so for me i've had their their the
solutions and again man for my depressed
friends out there please don't get mad
at me i'm not doing the thing i'm like
just put on a smile or any of that
[ __ ] because it doesn't feel like
that when when when you're like in the
and when you're fighting it it's
it's like you are
you're in a uh
i don't know why i'm keep i keep using
stupid gravity analogies but it's like
the gravity's been turned up on your
planet in every single way by so getting
out of bed you know like
by the way gravity and quantum mechanics
one of the most beautiful things about
our reality what the hell is each of
those things right so right this isn't
you're not just talking about happy
language it's still
physicists pretend they understand
something we're still at the very
beginning understanding this mysterious
world of ours that seems to be
functioning according to these
weirdly simple
and yet universally powerful laws
which we don't fully yet understand
so um please the metaphor and the
analogy of gravity okay thank you fully
fully applicable i don't know any other
way to put it then it's like somebody
turned the gravitational field of your
mattress up so everything is heavy heavy
your body's heavy you don't want to get
out of bed you will consider [ __ ] or
pissing the bed because you're just like
who gives a [ __ ] i'll just lay in my
[ __ ] and piss you're dying you're like
you're you're you're
it's none of it makes sense so
um
and i feel like in retrospect i'm making
what i what i've done a little like i
had more lucidity it was more of like a
when you're
uh right you know you're wrestling with
someone and you're just like well you do
yes it's different for you but for me if
i'm wrestling i'm not thinking about jiu
jitsu moves i'm like survival
so it's like that it is a struggle
like it's like uh you really
have to deliberately
yeah fight everything so
you
start so you can almost have a
conversation with the depression
and then what you do is you start doing
the opposite
of everything it's telling you to do
so it's telling you
lay in bed
so you get out of bed
it's definitely telling you don't
[ __ ] exercise you're gonna go [ __ ]
exercise that's not gonna do anything
you can't you probably have a heart
attack you really want to go outside
don't
go [ __ ] exercise and it'll feel
crazy and you won't want to do it if you
wanted to do it you wouldn't be
depressed like how often do you hear
like one of the symptoms of depression
you want to jog you want to get on a
bike you know you don't hear that that's
not a symptom so you start
at least
one one solution i
started doing the opposite of whatever
the voice is telling you do the opposite
that and then
suddenly that those the gravitational
field
diminishes a little bit it doesn't go
all the way away and that's where you
can fall right back into it because you
just feel even slightly better you're
like oh okay i fixed it you know really
i think if you like in
having been through therapy
the the
best solution would be
go to a [ __ ] therapist
as quickly as you can
just sit down with him and tell him
what's going on
i know what you're thinking how am i
gonna find a therapist just
do it google it go on yelp all this [ __ ]
feels
impossible you're like i don't want to
turn on the computer i don't do any of
this you just have to you have to you do
it if you're on fire you do it if you're
on fire and someone's like you know
here's a way to not be on fire just this
particular fire is
it doesn't make you want to run around
screaming it just makes you want to fall
asleep forever and that but those
little steps
i got lucky because it worked it worked
i started exercising i'd been on
antidepressants before
when i was originally diagnosed with it
and
it does help
you know i even with all the current
research coming out about
that maybe we were all wrong about our
understanding of depression i do feel
like
it helped in a certain way like it
definitely
it definitely like made me stop thinking
about it stop the intrusive thoughts and
but i don't know how much of that was
placebo or how much of that i don't know
but then also like i couldn't come
anymore that was the other [ __ ] up
thing like you're you can't have orgasms
and um
which might not sound like a big deal
but
um
you know when i told my therapist that
they actually took me off him because i
think she was realizing
that it started diminishing a little bit
but
the one i'm talking about now that
whatever episode or whatever you want to
call it i just got lucky because it
worked it worked and i started feeling
better thank god now if you suffer from
depression out there and you've had a
remission of the depression you know
it's it's really like it's scary to have
mental illness because
um
everyone gets bummed out i mean that's
just normal like you're going to get
bummed out and i want to do anything
sometimes it doesn't mean you have a
clinical depression you might just be
bummed out or grieving you might be any
number of things but when
i when i get really nervous
if some of those symptoms start
showing up and
um
at one point i felt like that was
happening again
and i did
inter-muscular ketamine therapy
which
now that was the damnedest thing
i've ever experienced aside from the
fact that ketamine is
immensely psychedelic
the
i i just remember going back to the
hotel after the
experience with a clinician and um
like you know it's like
with depression it's like a headache
that starts coming on but you're like
this headache might last for years it
might last for six months it might get
worse and worse and worse and so
i went back to the hotel room
and it was just
gone like i just felt normal i felt i
felt great it was like
the most remarkable thing ever so you
know look at the research on ketamine
right now it's like it's it's not like
[ __ ] it's not like woo science
there's really really good data out
there showing that something like
i think it's 60
i don't know what the percentage is but
percent of people with
uh depress and endogenous depression
when they
get ketamine therapy will experience
remission regardless of whether you trip
out or not it just does it does
something that i don't know if they know
what it is yet i don't care if they do
but but that one thing worked and
basically you keep fighting until
something works
exactly it's a survival issue and it's a
survival issue it's just i think because
it's kind of so slow-moving you might
even forget it's progressive
you or you know you could easily just
think that you're just a kind of bummed
out person or you start thinking that
these aspects of your
psychology are permanent when they don't
have to be
what about other people in your life
what advice would you give to people
that have loved ones who suffer from
depression
what are they to do
okay now this is really like
man it's really dark
here's
number one
this is what somebody told me when i
lost a friend of suicide you know
because when you lose a friend to
suicide when you lose a loved one to
suicide
you're going to blame yourself it's a
ever like in the in the circ in the
circle in the periphery of suicide there
is a
circumference of guilty people who all
feel like oh if only i'd said this at
the right time if only i'd listened more
if only i'd seen that warning sign or if
only this or that
it's interesting in that
with other
forms of like disease
you know
if if your loved one
dies from cancer say
more than likely you're not going to be
thinking like oh i should have cured
their cancer you know like you're it's a
tragedy but at least you're not like uh
if only i had you still might think
that's part of grief but um
it's not as sticky in many of the other
situations here the guilt can really
stay for a long time yep
so
you
number one
it's we're talking about a pro
progressive disease that can lead to
death and if somebody commits suicide
they wanted to commit suicide and at
least what i've been told is you're you
can't stop it it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen there are no magic
words there's nothing you could do so
you know people who've lost people to
suicide you know what i'm talking about
like you know you you can watch it
happen in real time and there's there's
nothing you could do
um
that being said
you know being
responsive to when it seems like
someone's really reaching out for help
and knowing that maybe
even it though it might if especially if
it's someone who's like doesn't talk
like this a lot of the time and
sentences start coming out of their
mouth
that if you weren't really paying
attention
might not seem like a big deal but for
this person it's kind of a novelist that
all of a sudden
that's happening
now there
that's when you can be a good listener
and you know open up to them and hear
what they're saying and see like oh [ __ ]
are they asking me for is this them
asking for help and even if you're like
i'm i don't know what to do
you know
uh at least you can like
start checking in on them you know start
like
help them understand that you're there
for them and then hopefully get them
into therapy get them to a doctor get
them to a professional who can like see
what's going on there so that and then
there's hope and even then there might
not be hope actually you know doctors
can't stop it there's no
sometimes it just that's the way it goes
but
you know i know that like um
being sensitive
if somebody's like all of a sudden
hitting you up or reaching out to you
that normally isn't like that
and just what's going on how are you and
just listen which in general
depression or not is probably a good
thing to do
yeah to to to to to truly listen it's
like are you okay yeah yeah
because people have you know i don't
this whole thing of like cries for help
man they don't sometimes they just look
like a weird text
you know something you don't realize the
for the person to send that [ __ ] text
they've been thinking about it all
morning they've been just trying to get
their [ __ ] get their phone up
from the floor
so you know
i think that that's it i mean i get what
i don't know i don't know i've had
friends like kill themselves so
and uh
many of them it wasn't like
sadly it was like i don't know i don't
know what could have been done but
but there's still
still a guilt in the back of your head
for the rest of my life for sure always
will be
yeah i mean yeah but again what are you
gonna do you but even that it's a part
of love
that's right that's right yeah that's
right you could yeah you know we feel
guilt gre part of grief is guilt you
know i like you we always could have
been better people
we always could have been better people
you getting a victor franco much yeah of
course
man search for meaning yeah
the invitation
to
live
your life as though you'd been on your
deathbed
and have been given the chance to go
back and not make the same mistakes
i i returned to that idea all the time
meaning it's like okay whatever you did
before
this moment
was too late
but now
you know this is where you can start
this is where you can start
and yeah so
i i think that for a neurotic like me
that's super important because otherwise
i'll just get like too lost in the weeds
of [ __ ] shitty things i did in the past
so speaking of victor frankl you and
hitler have the same birthday oh my god
you've really done your research
uh well i i often google um
famous people that have a birthday same
as hitler yeah and the the the person
that shows up you know is your face just
really big
you and hitler together just the pals
next to each other no it does not i'm no
but april 20th is an embarrassing
birthday for all my 420 friends out
there it's embarrassing you share a
birthday with hitler i think it's 420s
also has a humor and an uh a lightness
to it right it's embarrassing
especially life is embarrassing but if
you like weed and you're born on stoner
day and
you believe in reincarnation
do you realize like when you start
connecting the dots there if there is
like a bardo where you get to choose
your next life so you're like a shitty
generic np npc you're you're like of
course of course you would be born on
420.
it's computer games
yeah
but isn't it interesting that on that
same day
hitler is also born
i don't there's a
there's attention to that
um and that hitler's an artist
so it's like
that hippie mindset could go anywhere oh
yeah right like what yeah you know and i
i like i was just having this
conversation with a friend of mine who's
a wonderful skeptic
and
we were talking about this uh
which is
the thing where you start attributing
to the day you were born these kind of
significance and based on maybe people
who were born on that day maybe some
other things and you know it's like
think of how many people by now in the
course of human history have been born
on april 20th i mean
how many someone could probably do the
math and come up with some number close
to it
now
this is how you know how rotten hitler
is like he's the one that like [ __ ] up
every other the birthday for everybody
else but
i think where i heard that you're 420
is wim hoff
episode because he's also 47 420. yeah
so he
hitler beats even william hoff
look in terms of owning the date i think
if anybody
is is like well obviously there's
nothing you can do do to like fix it
hitler [ __ ] up a lot of things he
[ __ ] up that mustache he [ __ ] up the
name hitler he [ __ ] up 420 and
obviously he caused a horrific holocaust
that by the way talk about these
reverberations through time that we're
still experiencing there's still people
walking around with [ __ ] tattoos from
that [ __ ] so
but you know wim hof
you know people like wim hof there's a
little
they're like
whatever the opposite of hitler is you
know he too is creating ripples in the
lake that hopefully
uh respond to that of hitler yeah a very
cold [ __ ] lake and he's in in and
yeah so very cool
very very cold lake that he's happily
swimming around in but yeah you know i i
i try not to uh i try not to think about
like the the hitler thing on my birthday
that my dad would just every birthday he
would remind me that but do you think
all of us are capable of evil do you
think you're one of the sweetest people
i know just as a fan do you think you're
capable of evil sure
yeah i mean sure
definitely i think if you don't think
that you better you better watch out
because
come on how do you think you're not
capable of evil and p.s you are if
you're connected to the supply chain
friend
you're doing evil you're paying taxes
you're like you're supporting the
worst things in the world i mean you
know
like diffusion of responsibility it's
really curious or that there's the
circumference of responsibility where
it's like
bombs are going off somewhere that were
paid for
in some small part
by you by you some fractional if you if
american if an america if a drone
is flying over
a village in afghanistan and drops a
bomb
and you pay taxes then you could say you
have fractional
ownership over that drunk you're cog in
the machine of evil in some sense you're
in and
i know what you're gonna say well yeah
but i have to [ __ ] pay taxes like i
have no choice there's sales tax there's
this or that
take that attitude
it's the same thing that people on the
battlefield when they're
sending missiles into other tanks
they're thinking the same thing it's
just they're more directly responsible
for what's going on but in
in buddhism this idea of dependent
uh co-arising uh or yeah dependent
co-rising we're all connected we're all
part of this matrix we're all connected
meaning
we all share responsibility for the evil
in the world so even if you aren't
directly committing evil acts if you're
seeing something in the world and you're
thinking that's evil
you're probably not quite as separated
from that as you'd like to believe in
some
tiny infinitesimally
quantum way you you're connected so and
there's a sense
i've gotten to experience this
over and over that one individual can
actually make a gigantic difference
in
and so not only is there a diffusion
responsibility
there's a kind of uh paralysis about
well what can i do yeah
sure i understand but what can i do and
i think
just
looking at history
and also hanging out and
becoming friends but also interviewing
people that have had a tremendous impact
you realize
uh you're just one dude yeah you're like
you're like a normal person now you're
not that smart even like a lot of people
aren't
like in some kind of magical way where
you have a big head that's figuring out
everything no you
uh you just saw problems in the world
and you're like hey i think i'm going to
try to do something about this yeah you
stay focused and dedicated to it for
prolonged period of time
and refuse to quit refuse to listen to
people that tell you that this isn't
like impossible here's how others have
failed yeah no i'm
gonna i'm gonna do it that's it
that's it one person and then you kind
of the thing is when there's one person
that keeps pushing forward that way
there's humans are sticky they other
people follow them around and they're
like i'll help
i you know uh i'll help and then the
other people help and then the cool
people all gather together because they
kind of get excited about this way holy
[ __ ] we can actually make a difference
and they they form groups and then all
of a sudden there's companies and
nations that actually make a gigantic
difference it's interesting it all
starts with
one person often you know what if i
could push back slightly against that
it's never just one person it's like you
know
nobody ever talks about at least as far
as i'm aware you never hear about like
buddha's
great-grandmother you never hear about
that you never hear about that but if
not for that person no no buddhism
you know you know the people you're
talking about
they are the mo they're the tip of the
iceberg that pops up out of the
ocean of history and you never see
the the all the little things that
helped that happen and and so to me
this is where the real like how do how
do you help what's something you can do
well you know recognize that first that
you don't really you don't you might not
even be aware of how much you're
impacting people around you you might
think that that you're not or you might
think sure surely not in a way that
makes a big difference
but you have no idea these tipping
points and that that can lead to the
emergence of an einstein a gandhi a
martin luther king we can go on and on a
dostoevsky or whoever and so i think
that's where for me it goes back to tend
to the part of the garden
you can
touch and then
or even deeper than that
intention it was just like an uh and i'm
an idiot so i need an idiot's intention
which is
don't
if you
i heard the dalai lama say it
if you can help
help
if you can't help don't hurt
simple basic
dummy rules so that you can if possible
refrain from hurting which it might as
well be a form of helping
and the help doesn't have to be the
dramatic thing these little acts of
kindness
i don't know they they seem to have uh
maybe i believe in kind of karma but
they seem to have this
they can have this gigantic ripple
effect
i don't know i don't know why that is i
just i remember a lot of
little acts of kindness that people have
done to me and they they uh what do they
do
uh when they fill me with joy and hope
for the future they give me faith in
humanity
um yeah that somehow there's a uh
partially dormant
desire in our sort of collective
intelligence to do good in the world
that most of us want to be
uh good that want to do good onto the
world they want there's a kindness
that's kind of like
begging to get out you know
and those little acts of kindness do
just that and actually one of the
reasons i love austin and moved here is
realizing
just just noticing those little acts of
kindness all around me just for stupid
reasons people being really nice
it's it's weird and that that
that kindness combined with an optimism
for the future
it's just it uh
it's amazing what that can build yes
yes it's incredible and i know what
you're saying it's like
you know we we moved to this great
neighborhood and
at this point i think
three
maybe four of our neighbors have like
made food for us that just shows up with
like handwritten
lists of like things they like to do in
the area and their phone number if we
need help and it's like
holy [ __ ]
that's like
that it might seem like a little act but
it feels like some kind of atomic love
bomb just went off on your porch when
you're looking at that like what the
[ __ ] yeah you made me a a pie
this is incredible like this is
incredible so
and also it's another act to accept that
kindness with a it's like a lot of times
when i was like in boston or san
francisco certain big cities you can
think like oh okay well they're trying
to like somehow
um
that's not an act of kindness that's
some kind of a transactional thing to
build up a it's like a career move for
networking all that kind of stuff but no
if you just accept it for what it is a
pure act of kindness [ __ ] boston yes
yeah yeah because for me i go the
opposite route because i'm not even
though there is a part of me that might
be a little suspicious or something
where i go
to to push that [ __ ] back mentally is
i'm like i don't deserve this if they
knew yeah what a piece of [ __ ] i am
you're gonna bring me i don't never
bring cakes to my neighbors i would know
how to make a cake i don't know how to
make anything i have time i should be
bringing [ __ ] to my neighbors why didn't
i do that i should have brought
i never do that
it's okay if you're not careful you can
spiral into a vortex of self-hate from
the gifts you have to yeah you have to
learn how to in in that circuitry
you have to learn how to like
accept oh yeah i have that problem
really big yeah like like i don't
deserve this
like i don't
i get so much love from people i'm like
well yeah they love me because they
don't know me
that's my brain my little voice like
yeah you're not
you're not worthy
you're not you're not worthy of any of
this uh
kindness and all this kind of stuff and
that could be very uh
yeah it can shut you down it can be
debilitating and also it shuts the
person down i mean you're talking and
that's that's the dog size it pushes
them away too yeah it cuts off this
[ __ ] mystical circuitry so like the
best thing if that happens to you is
like accept it
joyfully and just eva just all that that
whatever that thing
inside of you whatever that little thing
is you know this is like in the
meditation i do
um it's it's an infuriatingly simple
meditation but um
when a thought emerges when you you are
resting your attention on your breath
and then inevitably
you think you get lost in your thoughts
and when you catch yourself doing that
you think
thinking
and then return your attention to the
breath so i like that so that when that
part of myself starts you know having
its little neurotic semi-seizure i can
just go thinking
whatever it's just another thought and
then eat the eat the
eat the banana bread or whatever they
gave you
what's the most
wild psychedelic experience you've ever
had in a dream in a vision doesn't have
to be a drug related
what's um
what's one that jumps to mind that was
like holy [ __ ] i'm happy to be alive is
this life okay this is amazing yeah the
oh yeah okay so
the one that pops to mind i've had a lot
of psychedelic experiences but in this
moment the one that pops to mind only
because it goes back to what you're
talking about
about this uh nietzsche's idea of
infinite return um
the
the uh
so i'm a burning man
and
uh are you going to burning me on this
time i'm not like i mean i have kids
right now i just want to be around them
my wife was being so cool about it and
she knows i love burning man she's like
go to burning man and i was gonna go and
then i just i just want to be around my
kids as much as i can right now but i've
never been to burning man so i don't
know how secretive it is
that i mean because quite high-profile
folks go yeah everyone knows elon musk
goes there
isn't it pretty open got a boat
you know
you know there's a it's called art cars
they all make art cars and like part of
the
part of the burn what's so beautiful
about it is like
you can't buy anything there man like
you you i'd i've heard
i don't know if this has changed
it's been a bit because of the pandemic
but
the only thing you could buy was ice and
coffee
and i think maybe that's changed i heard
some whisper that that's changed but
so
that means that
it's a gifting economy is what they call
it and so
people will just give you stuff talk
about having to struggle with deserving
stuff man what are you gonna [ __ ] do
when the camp next to you
is like every morning making the best
iced coffee that you've ever had in your
life and they just you're giving it all
away until it's all gone what are you
gonna do it's
it's the best
ever and then you're giving things to
people and then you you learn stuff like
you learn these really interesting
lessons like uh
one of the times i went there
got all these uh
strawberries looks might not sound like
a big deal but
when you're out there in the dust and
you're not at one of like the like
hardcore like luxury camps which do
exist out there
you know you've got these like items
where in my mind i'm like yeah these are
going to be just for me and my
girlfriend my special stash fruit and
this or that and then like
two days in
you're walking around your camp
with the strawberries that you were
coveting and everyone's so happy to get
like cold strawberries and you've
realized oh my god this feels so much
better than the way a strawberry tastes
so you learn
something experientially there uh which
is an incredible thing
it's an incredible thing um man now i'm
wishing i'd decide to go to burning man
have you been a few times yeah
i just know like
uh at least people were saying it was
elon musk's boat like yeah like this i
think it was like a it's like this
massive it's art cars and it was this
party on this thing you could just
anyone
can go
on the boat like no one's like there's
no guest list
you just go on there i never saw him
there but that you know everyone's
whispering elon musk is here
there's a secrecy there's all that kind
of stuff because you probably have to
respect that but at the same time there
it seems like the kind of people that go
there
i mean
the the rules of the outside world are
suspended
in the sense that
the um
the crime the aggression
the tensions all that seems to dissipate
somehow not all the way
not all the way there you know there's
you could look it up you know because
like there is tension there's a lot of
tension there between
um
it's called plug-in plays like you know
burning man like the history of burning
man is
fascinating it has its roots
in
the cacophony society is what it was
called which is a
sort of evolution of something that was
i think it was called the
god like the san francisco basically
there was like an art movement in san
francisco and i can't remember the name
of it maybe the suicide club or
essentially like
they were really into urban exploration
and uh meaning like breaking into like
old
abandoned buildings and stuff but part
of this
what this was was
you would prepare your life
as though you were going to kill
yourself you would get all your affairs
in order you would get so it's going
back to what we were talking about with
a cancer diagnosis you're like sort of
putting yourself into
that world of like i'm gonna get all my
affairs together so this is it and then
there was some i'm sorry for anyone
listening if i'm butchering this but i
think there was some really cool
initiation where they would blindfold
you and they would take you into some of
these abandoned buildings and you didn't
know where you were walking but they
would say like if you take one step
to the left you're gonna die
you're gonna fall off you're gonna fall
so please be careful so you're like
in the moment and then blindfold comes
off it's a big awesome party this
evolves into something called the
cacophony society there's a great book
called tales of the cacophony society
for people listening um
you know one of the uh
members of the cacophony society was the
author of fight club and so if you've
seen fight club like you could see
little ideas that were in the cacophony
society they were into
dadaism which i don't know a lot about
like i don't know it's but it's a
philosophical art movement
um
and then so
basically what was happening is like
they kept burning increasingly large
effigies
in san francisco
and they weren't allowed to do it and so
they took it out in the desert and
they were basing it on something called
a zone trip which is like you know
across this border
the rules of that old society are gone
and so
that was the original
burning man which was
these lunatics
out in the desert
launching like burning pianos out of
catapults
through the air doing like drive-by
shooting ranges like
no rules
wild magical beautiful insane madness
and then
it grew and grew and grew and grew until
you have burning man as it is today
which is still the most incredible thing
i mean obviously anytime you have like a
thing that's been around for a while
you're gonna get that it's not like it
used to be it's not as free as it used
to be so this or that but what's
fascinating about burning man someone
pointed this out to me
look on the ground no trash
no cigarettes
the ethic of like picking up your [ __ ]
there is like so intense so it's not
like the other festivals you go to where
there's just trash everywhere [ __ ]
scattered everywhere it's clean people
are picking up their stuff
people are like
uh really being conscious of like not
[ __ ] up the playa so i'm sorry don't
open this up and you don't get a burner
yapping about burning man they we won't
stop it'll be mourning but there's a
power
there but there is a power the culture
uh propagating itself through to the
stories that we tell each other and that
holds up
uh for burning man that like it's clear
that the culture has stayed strong
throughout the years yes so many people
so many
really interesting people
uh
speak of burning man as like a
uh a sacred place they go to to to
remind themselves about what's important
yes that's so interesting and it is and
it is i mean it's like you know there
are all these stories of like i love
guru stories i have a guru neem crowley
baba never met him he was rambasa's guru
at least not in the flesh but the story
of the guru is if you're lucky
you meet this being that
and we're not talking about you know
whatever the run-of-the-mill like
charlatans out there like i know for
sure that people
are in the world right now who
uh
when you're around them
you the thing you're talking about the
affirmation of
the potential of humanity and also just
an acceptance of yourself and
you know cultivate like seeing someone
who's cultivated
love or compassion or whatever but in
this way that is
i mean you would almost
you would rather me that being than like
a ufo land in your backyard it's like it
is the ufo it's a person but it's not
it's
everybody and nobody and somehow they
like
end up
conveying to you
ideas that you may have heard a million
times before but somehow within the
language itself is a transmission that
permanently
alters you and so these people exist
i think you could argue that burning man
the
the total thing
is a guru that a pilgrimage is involved
to get there
you
like it's not easy to get there and when
you get there
it's
it's going to teach you something
it's going to show you something it's
going to
and what maybe some of the stuff it
shows you might not be great but the
community
around you
will like
will
hold you as your like
whatever the thing is that's coming out
of it is coming out of you and even the
simplest activities the simplest
exchange of words have uh like just like
with the gurus
a profound impact somehow yeah something
about that place yeah
not to mention the insane
synchronicities like
insane synchronicities here and i think
like you know to get back to the notion
of sentience as a
byproduct of uh
a harmonized yet hyper-complex system um
see i think synchronicities like
like those kinds of systems are like
lightning rods for synchronicity so
cr crazy not just because your high
synchronicities
happen that are impo that are impossible
where you just have to deal with it and
and like you'll need something and
within a few minutes someone's like oh
here you here you go
and you mentioned but by the way burning
man because of
a psychedelic experience is it the
strawberries
or was it something else
what was what was the moment yeah that
was magical no it was dmt what
definitely
wasn't strawberries
no no i was more potent
yeah i was like smoking dmt
and
like
i i saw like
if you in the midnight gospel they're
these bovine creatures that have like a
long neck and a lantern head
so like
i i saw one of those things and
um
and you know i thought it was funny and
like
ridiculous because you hear like all the
terence mckenna stories of
the self-transforming machine elves or
all the
purple or the magenta goddess everyone
sees her i'm like
so this is what i get like
a [ __ ] cow with a lantern head like
that's where my brain is at and
interacting with this molecule
so then like
i look i look away
and again this is dmt so when i say look
away do i mean with my eyes shut i look
away our eyes open i look away i think i
shut
so it sounds weird to say look away but
however you want to put it that's what i
did
and i look back
and it's still there only now it's you
know because usually in like when you're
having those kinds of visions they go
away pretty quickly yeah this thing's
like moved
like shambled ahead maybe a few steps
just like a cow it's just like a cow
and then
that was when the
you know all the stories you hear about
it like going through some kind of tuber
or
some kind of light tunnel like a water
slide made of light that's
increasingly familiar that's the wildest
part of it it's like oh i know this
place
not like oh i've seen this in like you
know on like bong stickers but like oh
yeah this is that place you go to you
just remember oh this place and then
it was like i was in some kind of uh
i don't know how to put it a chamber a
technological chamber some kind of
supercomputer some kind of nucleus that
was technological
and it was inviting there was an
invitation of like
comment like come deeper into come
deeper in
and uh
you can talk to whatever it is over
there you don't talk but there's a
communication
and i
communicated
but my friends
i don't
i love my friends i guess i had some
sense in that moment that it would mean
complete obliteration or
who knows what and the response that it
gave back was
you can always go back there
and that's when i open my eyes i'm back
totally you know and ever since then
that that's caused me to revise my
my thinking on reincarnation
the idea that you die and you start as a
baby and then live your life again it
goes right into what we were talking
about i you know that that maybe data
you know that the [ __ ] i saw in nitrous
i don't feel dumb that my epiphanies are
all related to drugs but not all of them
are a lot of them but this notion of
like oh
is it that we're
imprinting into the medium of time space
every
thing we do
and that that is a permanent imprint a
frame that
upon
death
can be accessed in the same way we can
pull up
pictures on our phone or computers
and not only accessed but experienced
as though
in other words you could just jump in
you're still going to have your memories
it's going to give you a
the illusion of having been a kid and
gotten to that frame but no you just
decided to go back there
nostalgia whatever and
uh yeah you can jump around freely in
space and time yeah yeah you can go in
and out of time space but when you the
problem is when you go into time space
it's time so it's going to feel sticky
it's going to feel like you've been here
forever because you've dropped back onto
the track that nietzsche's talking about
um and uh i guess one of the qualities
of dropping into that frame is that you
forget
your
higher dimensional identity
what happened to the kyle with the
lantern
was that goodbye
he writes me letters sometimes
[Laughter]
never saw it again never never saw it
again but i put it in we put it in the
midnight gospel you know i like
pendleton was like
such a genius and he was he drew it for
me and then it just ended up as a part
of the show but by the way i uh i have
to admit that as a big fan of yours i
haven't watched the midnight gospel
because i've i've been waiting
it sounds like you do these stupid
things but ever since you talked to
maybe two years ago with joe
about it i've been waiting to do to to
watch it with like a special person on
mushrooms
oh that's been in my to-do
i don't know of course you don't have to
be on mushrooms to enjoy it but
for some reason i put it into my head
that this is something i want to do with
somebody else like experience it and get
wild
um because visually i mean i watched
uh a bunch of it just a little bit here
and there
but it's just visually such an
interesting experience
um
combined with everything else obviously
the ideas the avoi the voices and so on
but just visually it's like um
it's like a super psychedelic version of
rick and morty or something like that
like uh you know like farther out while
they're out there so yeah man the the
that's pendleton you know these are
these people i mean like
i was part of that
um
in the sense that like pendleton
gave ever like one of the reasons he's
like such a genius and great at making
stuff is like he's like
he really does a good job of just like
de-hierarchizing
potential like hierarchies that can
appear you know someone has to be like
driving the bus and that was pendleton
but he lets
he's
so inclusive there's a real punk rock
thing that he's doing which is like
he'll take everything and it kind of
mixes its way into the show but
one of the things
you know in
animation
it can get really strict with like
drawing the characters and like
the
like
trying to create continuity in the way
the character looks like and it can get
really brute for the animator it can get
brutally
precise like it has to be precise
but he figured out that if you just sort
of
it's not like obviously like clancy had
to look like clancy through the whole
show but if you allow the various people
animating it to sort of have their own
spin on it then suddenly it creates a
very psychedelic
you know the show looks more psychedelic
because it looks more organic and also
the amount of time
i had no idea the amount of time that
goes into
making
digital art
look like that is it's
insane the amount of work and comping
that stuff is just
crazy it's crazy well generally the
amount of time it takes
even just like a painting
when you uh i really enjoy watching like
artists do a time lapse and you realize
how much effort just into a single
image
goes into it you know hours and hours
and hours sometimes days sometimes weeks
and months nuts and then you just get to
see them work but they they they lose
themselves in the craftsmanship of it
and the the rhythm of it
and like because they're focused on the
so we're talking about robotics earlier
like on the little details like they're
never look well
most of the time isn't spent looking at
the big picture of the final result it's
looking at the little details yeah and
so on and they're but they're
nevertheless able to somehow
constantly channel the big picture the
final result my god yeah yeah the
respect i have for animators it's like
dear god the it's the craziest thing
when you watch it when you see what it
what it looks like and how much
time goes into it and how zen they have
to be because like no matter what you're
gonna have to cut stuff man and when
you're cutting like a few seconds of
animation that was someone's like month
maybe yeah you know and like they they
they understand but still it's like whoa
it's brutal and so the
they they have like this
zen
outlook on it which is really cool and
they watch podcasts that's the other
cool thing when you realize like oh
they're listening to podcasts or like
that's really cool
to see that aspect of it too but yeah
man i
you know yeah your voice is in the ears
of a lot of interesting people it's not
yours too
hello interesting person
animators
uh eating delicious food in the
cafeteria
i'm on your side he's against you i'm
with you yeah
uh do you have you have a beard
therefore you must be wise do you have
advice for young people
high school college
about how to carve their path through
life how to have a life
a career
that's successful that they can be proud
of or a life they can be proud of man
see this is what kind of this is what
sucks
about
my life is that it's been very
random
and very spontaneous so unfortunately i
don't get
that thing where i could be like well
here's what i did yeah because it's like
i don't like i
i inherited
twelve thousand dollars from my
grandmother here's what you do kids you
inherit twelve thousand dollars when
your grandmother dies and then you need
to be dumb enough to think that that
twelve thousand dollars is gonna help
you live in la for a year so then what
you do is you move to la with twelve
thousand dollars
and you find a shitty
place that you live at and then you use
that money to buy acid and synthesizers
and then you run out of the money and
then
you and then you have to get a job
and so then because you think it'll be
fun to work at a comedy club
you get a job at the comedy store and
then
you know that's how it happened for me
and none of there wasn't i never was
never had the confidence to be like oh
i'm going to be a stand-up comedian
no way i just thought it'd be cool to
work in that building i thought the
building looked cool and so
but then like because like you work at
the comedy store you get stage time it's
there
it's the reason like yours you work
there is at least in those days because
it's not like they're paying like a [ __ ]
ton of money for you to answer phones at
a comedy club
and so
you know i started going on stage and
then like i just got lucky
because rogan saw me have like a very
rare good set i didn't know he was in
the room or out of bombed you know and
then like because he thought i was funny
and he liked talking to him he started
taking me on the road with them and then
you know so i don't know man i i think
uh
was there an element to there's a
beautiful weirdness to you as a human
being
was there was there uh
like a pressure to conform ever
to hide yourself from the world
or or the the twelve thousand dollars
and the ass would give you the
confidence you needed to be yourself no
no i don't like i instill i'm no i i
think
sure there's that pressure and like you
know
whenever you're you're beginning to
really differentiate from your parents
but then you go back to hang out with
your parents you'll feel you can feel
that it's not like they even want you to
conform but you'll just you could slip
into that whatever that was so i
remember that when i would go back and
like
visit them and stuff and surely
conformity or the pressure to like
not be individual or whatever it's
everywhere man do you think you made
your parents proud
no no no no well i think that um
when my mom died
i i felt successful in the sense that i
was
able to
support my i was i was making money from
doing stand-up in my i didn't need help
i was like as i was supporting myself
with art and doing good what i thought
was great then so
and i think she like had because she had
witnessed
me literally failing i mean which is by
the way i think part of if you want to
be
an artist or successful you you kind of
have to fail like there if if
and if there was a guaranteed
route from
sucking to not sucking or from
like
the neophyte phase of whatever the art
form is and you know some intermediary
phase then i think a lot more people
would do it but
there really is no guarantees in it
especially the stand-up comedy it's like
you'd have to be a maniac to want to
think that that's going to work out for
you you have to so you're going to
there are obviously exceptions but
for me it was like
a long slog
you know and that's scary for a mom so
but that being said
when she was
dying like she did recognize that i was
like not slogging anymore and she did
say
she said you did it
and
that's cool but
and you know i would love for her to see
me now like now it'd be way cooler but
maybe she does i don't know she's
listening to
your podcast elsewhere in the other
in the bardo
yeah
yeah however long that lasts
reconfiguring the whole process to start
again
um you're as a father now how did that
change you
yeah that's the big change man that's
the thing you made you made a few
biological
i reproduce yeah i made biological
entities i mean like what came in my
wife let's face it like i would love to
say i made them but the womb whipped
them up um
but
it is the
yeah it's the best it's i've never
experienced anything like it
before it is the
as far as i'm concerned the greatest
thing that has ever happened to me and
and that's why i was able to answer your
niechi question with like hell yes [ __ ]
yes that's great i get to be around my
kids again i'll always be around my kids
always be around my children
that's incredible that's the joy so like
so for me
the part of myself that used to torture
myself more especially like around like
my mom dying feeling like i wasn't that
there enough for her wishing that i had
spent more time with her wishing i'd
spent more time with my dad wishing that
like
you know looking back at like how like i
was just so desperately trying to evade
the fact that she
was dying
uh
and through and in that evasion
successfully like distanced myself from
her and like
in ways that i really wish i hadn't uh
i'm just saying that cause like it's one
of my regrets it's like a big regret i
have a lot of little regrets but that's
a big one and so
when you have
kids
you look back
at everything you did and you think like
[ __ ]
if i'd gone left at that point instead
of right
if i had eaten who knows what if i'd
eaten like a turkey sandwich
when my balls were
creating the [ __ ]
that was gonna make my kids would i have
a different kid
would this being not exist in my life
like you start looking at everything and
you realize like
oh thank god thank god for every single
thing that happened to me because it all
led up to this and oh for me that is the
that's
that it's like
it frees you in this it liberates you
because you realize like oh wow it's
clumsy and selfish and
and and at times rotten
if i've as i've been in my life
that did not impede
the universe
at all from allowing this these two
beautiful beings to exist in the world
so maybe all of it enabled all of it
like a concert
perfectly led up to that
little beautiful moment
is there ways
you would like to be a better father oh
yeah for sure absolutely i there's a
there's an actual
i read something in a book it's called
good enough the mantra for a parent
good enough because when you are in the
presence of something you love
more than
you've ever experienced love
you
you want to be perfect like you wanna be
i can't i gotta work man i gotta go on
the road i've gotta work i gotta support
the family so i that means i have to
work like
i work you know you know what it's like
having a podcast you [ __ ] work man
and
uh
you know it's a full-time job because
you know i do stand up too and all the
other stuff so i feel
so sometimes i i feel like oh my god i
want to spend more time with him like i
should be spending more time with him
but then also
i want to create i want to work i i like
being like
the provider
so
that's something i i feel guilty about
you know right now and struggling how to
balance that correctly
and meanwhile time just marches on
it just goes it goes
and all of this
will be forgotten
both you and i
but forgotten
in time that's what i say to them every
time i'm putting them to bed
we
we will be lost in the sands of time you
know that i bet you know this poem you
know that poem ozzy mandius yes
can i read you a plot
okay
let's let's end our conversation in the
poem i love it it's by
pierce by shelley probably
mispronouncing the name
but i think the right way to pronounce
it thank you thank you
um
i'm ozzy mandius i met a traveler from
an antique land who said
two vast and trunkless legs of stone
stand in the desert near them on the
sand half sunk as shattered visage lies
whose frown and wrinkled lip and sneer
of cold command
tell that its sculptor well those
passions read which yet survive stamped
on these lifeless things the hand that
mocked them and the heart that fed and
on the pedestal these words appear
my name is ozymandias king of kings look
on my works ye mighty and despair
nothing beside remains around the decay
of that colossal wreck boundless and
bare the lone and level sands stretch
far away
all gone
behold the the king look at my works ye
mighty and despair
and despair
uh even though we'll be forgotten in the
sands of time
duncan i'm just so glad that you exist
and you put so much love into the world
over the past many years that i've
gotten a chance to enjoy it by being
your fan
thank you so much for continuing that
and for sharing a bit of love with me
today can we be friends let's be friends
in real time in the real world in 3d
space nothing is real but yes in this
particular slice of the
multi-dimensional world we live in
it will be an honor and a pleasure thank
you for having me on your show love you
duncan i love you thank you lex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with duncan trussell to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from duncan trestle himself
you are essentially just a cloud of
atoms
that will eventually be aerosolized by
time
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you